a dot-org
and now we're live for the next three
hours with nationally syndicated talk
show host Thom Hartmann he sits down
with book TV for in-depth to answer your
questions and discuss his many books
including the crash of 2016 rebooting
the American Dream and threshold
Tom Hartman how did you get into radio I
got into radio when I was a teenager I
first of all when I was maybe nine years
old I I built a little 100 milliwatt
transmitter and which will reach like
three houses around your house and I had
a record player I was very into
electronics I was a ham radio operator
when I was 13 and I build a little radio
station and I did that at home as a kid
and then when I was 16 I was doing I was
I got a job at in at MSU in Brody Hall
in the radio station each of the major
dorms had a radio station so I was on WB
Rd as I recall and I did that for about
six weeks
made a tape got a job at at witl witl am
an FM lansing michigan in the which it
was the country-western station country
station number one station in lansing it
was great it was a weekend you know DJ
and I thought I hated country music and
I discovered that I absolutely loved
country music you know that was a
teenager in the 60s and it was like rock
and roll or nothing and I and I worked
there for years so and then went to to
do an all-night show progressive rock
show did top 40 and then went back to
back to whittle ended news for seven
years until 78 and then I got out of
that and then in 2000 to November of
2002 Thanksgiving we were living in
Vermont and Louise and I drove back to
Michigan to visit her family for
Thanksgiving and all the way there all I
could get was actually it was odd it was
like Sean Hannity show repeated itself
three or four times on that 14-hour
Drive and he was doing a live remote
from a Habitat for Humanity and only he
was calling it Hannity for Humanity and
was talking about how no liberal is
going to get this house and which kind
of offended my sensibilities but more
than that I was thinking you know half
the country votes Democratic roughly
it's not
were a totally read country were a
purple country there's got to be a
market for the left-wing version of what
Hannity is doing so I wrote an op-ed for
common dreams and I think probably
around December of 2002 titled talking
back to talk radio which basically was a
business plan you know I've been in
radio I've been in the business I know
how it works
here's you know here's how you here's
how you can do it from a business point
of view here's how you do it from a
programming point of view and put that
out there and then thought you know I
had a we had in 97 we had sold in a
travel or an ad agency in Atlanta and so
we were essentially retired and I
thought I would be fun to try this out
see if we can do this so putting my
money where my mouth was so we found a
radio station in Burlington Vermont that
would put me on the air for two hours on
a Saturday morning after the swap meet
and for a few months their idea morning
show most about half the calls I got was
that John Deere tractor still available
you know but but you know again we made
a tape and took that to ie America Radio
Network which at the time was the only
progressive radio network in America
preceded Air America was out of Detroit
was owned by the UAW and they picked me
up in under three and put us on 29
stations and Sirius XM or serious at
that time XM was a competitor at the
time and that's how the show started and
then you know whenever Ellen and the
shelling I needed robbed me a spectacle
out of Chicago and meet with them and
Johnson they had read my article and
they were thinking of starting a network
based on what I had written about and
they did they started air America and
after a year or so of competing with air
America it was two years whatever it was
they started syndicating my show and
when but I always owned the show I think
I think I was the only show but Ring of
Fire was the other one Papantonio in
Kennedy's show the only two shows that
we're actually owned by the hosts as
opposed to be an employee
why do you think air america went under
there I think was a mixture of things
the biggest one was that they were
undercapitalized Fox News you know Roger
Ailes had back when he was in the Nixon
White House had proposed or signed off
on a proposal for something called GOP
TV and you know which kind of a early
fox news Nixon couldn't raise the money
and so it never happened and then he met
Murdoch and Murdoch said sure you know
let's do this but they've lost a hundred
million dollars a year for roughly five
years before they made any money so you
could say you know hey Sean Hannity lost
them in aggregate maybe four hundred
million dollars isn't that a terrible
failure
well no after the fifth year they
started making money they caught an
audience and they've now they make a lot
of money there America when they
declared bankruptcy I think that they
had gone through something like sixteen
or seventeen million dollars over a five
six year period it's not a lot of money
for a ready for a national radio network
particularly when part of the business
model was leasing and you know radio
station so I think that being
undercapitalized was their biggest sim
there were some management problems you
know some of the people in management
really shouldn't have been there and and
there were some programming issues that
I disagreed with I thought that they
were creating some programs that were
more like television than radio there's
a real big difference in those mediums
but I think the real big problem is they
ran out of cash in several of your books
you refer to yourself as a serial
entrepreneur yeah yeah I I started my
first business when I was seventeen it
was a TV repair shop and stereo repair
shop across the street from Michigan
State University I was in head shop
wasn't it was in the bag of a head shop
yeah and we called it the electronics
giant in our logo was a joint with
within TV antenna and then we got a
little less hippie when it what I was
doing was a the the guy who owned the
head shop I rented a shelf from him for
$25 a month and people would bring
electronic equipment in to have it fixed
I'd pick
every night take it home and fix it and
bring it back the next day and he'd
collect the money and he took a
percentage of the money to it he was a
quarter and that we grew out of that
shelf in a head shop in about four
months and so we moved down the street
and rented a place and ended up with
four technicians and six or seven
employees total my soon-to-be wife was
our bookkeeper and it was the first
business I have around it was also the
the only business that I've started that
went down in flames and I learned a lot
from that I learned an awful lot from
that
so yeah and then after that you know
really surgeon herbal tea company we
started an advertising agency in 78
reason I moved to New Hampshire and
started community for these kids in 83
we moved back to Atlanta and started a
travel agency built that from nothing up
to about six million dollars value got
on the front page of The Wall Street
Journal sold in 86 retired to Germany
moved to Germany with our kids for a
year working living add in and working
with the nonprofit organization I've
been working with since 1978
Salem International that we had based
the community for these kids on and then
we came back in 87 from Germany and back
to Atlanta and started an advertising
agency and that's the company I sold in
97 when we moved to Vermont to quote
retire and started the radio show which
just turned into this you know it was
going to be a hobby and now I'm doing
four hours of media every day five days
a week and where are you living
I lived on the south west here in
Washington DC when did you start and why
did you start writing books I again this
goes back to my childhood my mom was an
English major she graduated magna [ __ ]
laude from MSU back in the late 40s and
her aspiration was to be a writer and
she held writers the way people today
think of movie stars and I mean she uses
and my dad had 20,000 books in the house
the whole basement I mean he had
organized like a live
he was a very organized guy and I
started writing as a as a young teenager
by the time I moved out of the house
when I was 16 I had 56 rejection slips I
had papered my bedroom wall with
rejection slips mostly for bad poetry
and short stories and I just kept kept
doing I died now I've got I think around
25 books in print well the first several
books a you wrote were about attention
deficit disorder yeah for several that I
published I'd written probably 10 or 12
books before that but none of them
thankfully were ever published arthur c
clarke says your first million words are
practice and it's true but yeah
ATD and that was the the product of two
things when i was i was the executive
director of the residential treatment
facility at the new hampshire salem
Children's Village and my wife was the
program director and so my job
principally was to raise money and get
publicity and things like that the
administrative stuff but I noticed that
virtually all the kids that came in were
coded as hyperactive or back then it was
referred to as hyperkinesis syndrome
hyperkinetic children kind of like and
in 78 the year that we started that the
year before that then feingold had
published his book why your child is
hyperactive and he proposed that it was
food dyes that salicylates specifically
that these children were reacting to
with a functionally and allergy he was a
pediatric allergist by the way so he had
a certain bias we did a study on our
kids over 6 month period putting them on
his diet and we found that out of 34
kids we had one kid that we could turn
on and off like a light switch but
putting salicylates into her taking them
out of his diet but he also had just
horrible psoriasis and they seemed to
make his psoriasis worse so I think that
for a very small subset of the
population there is that allergy
connection but for most I think it's
just a way of brain wiring and so I
published my first published piece on
that was in
must have been around 1980 and it was in
the Journal of worth of Molecular
Psychiatry it was on the hyperkinetic
syndrome suggesting that it was not a
disease but simply a different way of
having your brain wired and then when
one of our children was diagnosed with
ADHD in high school in the mid 80s and
the in the psychologists at the room
with them and said you know forget about
going to college you know you should
become on a car mechanic you know you're
good with your hands you know and by the
way if you're going to be a car mechanic
work on the foreign-made cars because
the pay is a lot better you know if
you're fixing Mercedes you can make more
money than fixing Fords and at this
point my son is like tears in his face
and I was because he wanted to go to
college and I thought this sucks it was
a terrible way to describe this and so I
wrote my first book a DD a different
perception essentially to my son and
saying you're not broken nothing wrong
with you you have a different skill set
than many other kids but you also
there's a lot of people in your tribe
and he now has a master's degree in
science running a business of his own
face now in that field god bless him so
yeah so I wrote a couple of books on
that then that became a Time magazine
did a story on and it became a national
bestseller and so my publisher was like
I found another blogger not another
broken who are we talking about this is
a quote from you he's the poster child
for a DD and if he didn't have a DD we
wouldn't have the United States of
America probably Ben Franklin it's been
a while since I wrote those books yeah
that it clearly in fact there's in a DD
a different perception i profile a
couple of people and as I recall it was
Ben Franklin Thomas Edison
Sir Richard what's his name same name as
the guy who married Elizabeth Taylor
Burton Burton yeah famous British
explorer he was he was such a classic
case probably Richard Burton Elizabeth
Taylor's husband yet he took it out
given his bouncing around
what not why'd he say that about Ben
Franklin Ben Franklin never held one job
for more than three years he reinvented
himself over 30 times literally
completely changed his profession moved
all lived all over the world he was
easily bored I think that the ATD is a
can be for a person who is who has a
lower IQ is is more of a challenge for
person like Franklin who is a genius and
had a DD it can be a really useful
combination so I think for everybody it
can be useful combination so would you
say that he was a serial entrepreneur
yes he definitely was an inventor and
you know writer and publisher and and
like I said he helped create the United
States of America 2004 what would
Jefferson do where to death will come
from I wrote that book because I I kept
encountering revisionist history
specifically and particularly about
Jefferson there was kind of a resurgence
of interest in Jefferson I think largely
after 9/11 but there were there are a
couple of historians I'd put that in
quotes I'm not sure that they have
degrees in history who were suggesting
the Jefferson was a bible-thumping
Christian and that you know it was part
of this whole America was founded on
Christian values mean that there's
several very well organized groups out
there pushing and and a number of other
myths about Jefferson that that I
thought were important to knock down and
and just tell the actual story of
Jefferson's life and what he did and
what what he was what he was promoting
well I think you're right about the fact
living in New Hampshire you discovered
some Jeffersonian materials in a house
you're something yeah it was Vermont
actually it was we in fact that's what
really got me into it you're right I
geez I'd forgotten about that how could
I forget that
time passes right we bought this house
in 2001 I think it was in Montpelier and
in the Attic there was a couple of boxes
of old books the attic of the carriage
house that was attached to it and they
were just horribly weather damaged you
know they had no value whoever had the
house before it's just left them there
and in fact they'd been left there for a
long time they were a bunch of
newspapers in the boxes from the 1930s
and there was a 10 or 20 volume set it
was a 20 volume set the collected
writings of Thomas Jefferson which has
only been published once in the history
of the United States
it was 1909 by the Thomas Jefferson
Memorial Association and it had his
personal Diaries all his letters and his
autobiography and just all this stuff
and I spent a year I mean I did I was
quote retired I spent a year just
reading just living inside Jefferson's
brain and and then you know like I said
I'm I'm reading all this stuff out out
in the world it completely contradicts
what I just learned from and I realized
that there's there's something to be
said for an objective voice of history
you know Jefferson obviously in a lot of
his writings was thinking about the
posterity was thinking about his own
reputation and presented himself well as
you would expect but but the history is
fairly clear so yeah that led me to that
book that actually also led me to I when
I started writing that book the first
draft became the book on equal
protection actually because it was
Jefferson would be horrified by the idea
that a corporation as a person
why because well first of all the
corporate form in its modern form
largely didn't exist back then it's but
although the British East India Company
was the first modern corporation Queen
Elizabeth II the first Charter did in
what 1600 1601 the first corporation was
the Golden Hind she did that and she
made a fortune on that her and the
members of parliament so then they
chartered the British East India Company
and in 1773 Jefferson had published a
pamphlet called
a summary view of the rights of British
Americans as I recall it's been almost
two decades since I read this stuff and
it was basically a booklet booklet about
how to be a good British citizen in
North America that was in the summer in
the fall late fall early winter the boss
excuse me England was suffering through
a recession serious serious recession
worldwide recession and so they passed
the Tea Act which for some reason most
people think was a tax increase on tea
but what it was actually the East India
Company's stock was almost all owned by
members of the British Parliament and
the royal family and the British East
India Company was like going down the
tubes
they were because of this recession and
they had a monopoly on most of the
businesses in the United States and and
tea was what everybody drank people
didn't didn't drink coffee in the in the
early colonies and there were every
every block or every other block had a
tea shop on it they were the kind of
cultural centres and so this the Tea Act
of 1773 was the largest tax cut at that
point in time corporate tax cut in
history of the world but not only had
the the English India Company have ten
over ten million pounds as I recall and
tons would be too much but whatever it
was it was a massive amount of tea in
stock in the UK they'd already paid tax
on and so it was a tax rebate on all
that stuff was tax cut combined with a
rebate so they got money back from the
government and then the goal was to sell
that tea into North America because the
problem that they were having in North
America was about half the tea being
consumed in all these tea shops was from
quote smugglers you know it was from the
Dutch trading companies that were
trading American trading companies it
was being brought in illegal
and they tried stopping that trade they
you know go all the way all the way back
to Captain Kidd you know let's hire a
pirate and you know stop they they
couldn't stop there was no way they
could stop so they decided to undercut
it and so the British East India Company
was bringing all this super discounted
tea into the United States and the
citizens of from Philadelphia to Boston
just freaked out and and started this
huge campaign to block the tea from even
coming in and Charleston they prevented
them from coming into the harbors in DC
they prevented them from coming into the
harbors but they finally docked in
Boston and that led to to basically a
million dollar in today's dollars act of
vandalism they vandalized three of the
ships quietly respectfully interestingly
enough but I I tracked down a copy of
the only eyewitness account and got the
original book was published in 1883 by
bliss and company and it was George
12:3 or George Roundtree Hughes and it
had a long title you know and in fact he
was the guy who you came up with the
phrase Boston Tea Party and because if
they'd all sworn an oath of silence to
each other and this was 50 years later
and pretty much everybody else was dead
and he had been sixteen or seventeen
years old when he participated in and so
he wrote the book and and it was
remarkable and it was an act of
vandalism against the largest
corporation in the world so when you say
why would Jefferson be horrified by the
idea that a corporation was a person
after the Boston Tea Party
Jefferson stopped talking about how to
be a good citizen in the United States
of the UK and started talking about
separation and this led right to 1776 so
in a very real way America was founded
on a revolt against corporate power and
that's what you write an unequal
protection the American Revolution was
in fact provoked by the misbehavior of a
British corporation our nation was
founded in an anti corporate
our Furies that's true you also one of
the themes that I picked up in your
books was that we were not an
aristocracy did the the white men who
formed our nation were not necessarily
an aristocracy a rich land owning
aristocracy yeah that was one of the
most fascinating things that I that I
got out of reading Jefferson's stuff and
and and then digging deep into the
history of that era that is in what
would Jefferson do the myth of the of
the rich founders and there's been a
couple of good histories about that
published since that time the wealthiest
man among the people who signed the
Declaration of Independence was was John
Hancock and his net worth in today's
dollars or in two thousand four dollars
when I wrote the book would be about
seven hundred thousand dollars he was
not mind bogglingly rich guy land had
very little value some of them had fancy
houses but they were fancy houses by the
standards of North America they weren't
they wouldn't have even been considered
a Squires house in the UK these people
were not rich there were rich people at
the time of the American Revolution
the Johnson family for example who had a
castle on the Hudson with several
hundred African slaves and several
hundred European slaves as you know
knights of the round table I mean they
had kind of recreated this whole time
they were fabulously wealthy and there
were a number of families like that
virtually all of them left that that
family fled to Canada during the
revolution so after the Revolution I
mean Jefferson died in and bankrupt
Washington died bankrupt Madison was
having problems they were all just
skating by and among the slave owners
the slaves were their principal asset
which is terrible and grim part of our
history also and then all the other part
was you know Jefferson worked
aggressively to try to stop slavery
which is a part of history not so often
told when he was
in his early 20s in the Virginia House
of Burgesses he introduced legislation
to end slavery in Virginia and he was so
punished by it they passed a law saying
that if anybody in Virginia free to
slave that that slave would be arrested
as I recall it was like something like
two years of hard labor and then sold
back into the slave market so I just you
know I kind of wanted to set the record
straight from your book 2013 book the
crash of 2016 history tells us that when
the foundations collapse and the
Society's cultural core is hollowed out
and the madness takes hold its members
will pretend all as well life seems to
go on as average citizens try to get by
while the very rich who understand
what's happening consolidate their power
and wealth before the final crash yeah
it's a fairly typical cycle people see
these things coming when we started the
Children's Village back in the 70s it
was a vegetarian program I've been a
vegetarian since 68 and or maybe 67 and
so we get some prominent that Rotarians
on our board and Gloria Swanson was one
of them and I used to go to New York
every six months and we just make dinner
together in her apartments in chat stay
up into little wee hours and talk and
she'd tell me these wild stories and she
Joe Kennedy was the perennial object of
her scorn and she talked about how Joe
Kennedy got out of the market how him
and all his buddies knew that the crash
was coming in 1929 and all this kind of
stuff I thought that was interesting it
seems like we're recycling that now
we're sort of in a similar period and
back to the crash 2016 book you write in
here that the beginning of the end of
the crash of 2016
occurred in 2009 in January when Barack
Obama became president what we hoped
would be the beginning of the end the
first stimulus I mean at the time we
were losing 750,000 jobs a month
and that 800 million dollar stimulus
that we did here in the United States
will a third it was tax cuts which don't
generally stimulate the economy and was
therethis at the very bottom of the
economic ladder most of them weren't but
it kind of jump-started us out of the
horror that we were experiencing them
but then they couldn't they couldn't get
a second one or a larger one we really
you know I think it was the Robert
rusher or Paul Krugman and said there
was a two trillion dollar hole on the
side of our economy we patched it with
an 800 billion dollar patch it wasn't
enough and we also didn't change the
fundamentals we didn't reinstate
glass-steagall we didn't break up the
big banks we didn't hold the banksters
accountable for what they did the we
didn't change the derivative markets we
didn't make them more transparent or
even just stopped them all together at
the time of in 2007 just before the big
crash we had I think there was in the
neighborhood of eight to nine hundred
trillion dollars in derivatives out
there these are kind of magical
securities that are made up out of an
underlying they derive their value from
another line asset in this case
mortgages so you have a million dollars
of the mortgages it put an insurance
policy on it for a million bucks in many
place of bet on that insurance plan
which is what he was doing in any place
of bet on that insurance policy say a
100 million dollar bet that that million
dollars won't go bad then you place a
billion dollar bet on the hundred
million dollars at any place a hundred
billion dollar debt on the billion
dollar debt and they just get bigger and
bigger bigger I mean the the the growth
the GDP of the entire planet is in the
neighborhood of 56 trillion dollars and
we had 800 to 900 trillion dollars worth
of derivatives he'sjust best out there
and when that collapsed it was massive
get down to around three or four hundred
trillion nobody's really sure of these
numbers by the way because it's not you
know Bank of International Settlements
sort of collective vehicle and we're
back up now the best guesses to in the
neighborhood of seven to eight hundred
trillion dollars and derivatives so it's
like we didn't fix these things which is
why I'm suggesting that that
crash has not stopped actually and in
fact it's going to going to happen again
only worse who are the economic
Royalists that you refer that's a phrase
that I borrowed with with
acknowledgement from Franklin Roosevelt
and is my favorite of his speeches was
his acceptance speech in 1936 and in
Philadelphia as I recall July of 1936
and where he talked about the economic
Royalists and he said you know out of
this industrial order it would seem it
was fairly predictable that a group of
economic Royalists would arise to take
to try to take control of this you know
these economic Royalists tell us you
know he just he went after him and it
really was you know it was the big money
fat cats who crashed the economy in 29
and who fought FDR throughout his
presidency and it's the big money fat
cats were crashing our economy right now
Tom Hartman in your book rebooting the
American Dream the math is pretty simple
when the uber rich are heavily taxed
economies prosper and wages for working
people steadily rise when taxes for the
rich or cut working people suffer and
economies turn into casinos yeah and if
you look at the the time in the United
States when the middle class was most
prosperous this is the thing you know
when we measure prosperity the United
States we tend to look at big numbers
like GDP or the stock market those are
not really the numbers that we should be
looking at if we're concerned about
society as a whole it should be how
healthy is the middle class and so what
is what has happened over the years is
that you know with this with this
massive deregulation the middle class
has been collapsing steadily and the
very wealthy of gotten super wealthy I
got this up close and personal I learned
this lesson myself in 1974 v Terry
O'Connor was my business
he recently passed away and he and I own
this herbal tea company and we were
making a lot of money it was in fact it
was a side business of the herbal tea
company we were selling ginseng to Larry
Flynt he was selling in hustler magazine
and he made a million bucks literally
and we made a couple hundred thousand
which was big money in 73 and my CPA
came to me and he said you know you're
getting close to as I recall it was a 40
or 50 percent tax bracket and he said
you need to stop taking money out of
your company and reinvest it grow the
company because it's an asset that you
own also and it won't be taxed but you
know if you just keep taking this money
out as pay and so I did and you know we
added we added another product line we
added another seven employees we grew
the company and that's what happened
back in the 70s when the top tax rate
was ninety percent or seventy four
percent I forget when it dried a I think
Johnson dropped it down to 74 percent in
67 so yeah it was and and back then the
average CEO made thirty times would
employ his employees made I probably
made six or eight times with my
employees are making at that time and
and there was a reason for it if you
made more than that you got hit with
these huge taxes so keep the money in
the company pay your employees well all
our employees had health insurance all
our employees were well paid and we had
other benefit programs for them when we
opened the travel agency in 83 in
Atlanta we had we had health care or we
had not only health care for all our
employees most of the people working the
travel agents were young women who had
kids we built a daycare center inside
travel agency and it was just a little
corner but it worked
companies don't think like that anymore
now it's how do we squeeze every penny
out of this so that we can pump that
money up to the guy at the top for the
stockholders and if there is a high tax
level at the top then the guys at the
top say okay I got my 30 times that's
cool you know I mean it used to be that
CEOs lived in the neighborhoods of the
middle-class with the exception of the
very very goober rich and
our economy is so different now than the
economy that I grew up in good afternoon
and welcome to book TV on c-span - this
is our monthly in-depth program where we
invite one author on to talk about his
or her body of work this month it's
talk-show host and author Thom Hartmann
as he indicated earlier he's the author
of about 25 books or so and we'll be
talking about them over the next three
hours showing you those covers as well
but as we always do on book TV live
programs this is an interactive program
and we want to hear from you as well so
if you'd like to interact with our guest
author Tom Hartman here here's several
ways of doing so we're going to begin
with the phone numbers - 0 - 7 4 8 80
200 if you live in the East and Central
time zones - OH - 7 4 8 8 - 0 1 for
those of you in the mountain and Pacific
time zones you can also text mr. Hartman
a message to 0 to 7 1 7 9 6 8 4 again
that's just four text messages and if
you do send one please include your
first name and where you're texting from
the city live in we have other ways via
social media of getting ahold of our
guests and that includes email book TV
at c-span org is our email address you
can make a comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV and finally
Twitter at book TV is our Twitter handle
and we'll begin taking those in just a
few minutes mr. Hartman I want to show
some video and then have you explain
what this is oh all of the money that
was spent on television advertising by
John McCain and and Barack Obama
together Obama spent about what six
hundred million dollars
five eight hundred million dollars it
was 1.2 billion all in oh he and she
move on.org everybody on the left was
about 1.1 22 and on the right was it got
under six or seven hundred million yep
right okay so it was it was less than
two billion two billion dollars is chump
change for the health insurance industry
right now it's chump change for the
pharmaceutical industry right now it's
walking around money for the for the oil
industry
right now they could these large
corporations can now say to any
politician in America we will make you
and you will be where you are forever
and when you retire you'll have a good
job with us for millions and millions of
dollars a year or we will destroy you
and they can absolutely make good on
that threat how is that a good thing for
America well let's just start with the
very fact that that wasn't my intent of
Rana Dana was here in Chennai was the
outcome but what I'm not blaming you for
that I'm just saying look what what do
we do now
right and you and I agree that's not a
good thing what do we do lipid IFC I
believe in more speech and I believe
that the American people are smart
enough to understand and I give the
American people credit for being smart
enough to know when they're trying to be
bought so I am Not Afraid of some big
evil corporation who's going to run a
bunch of 30-second ads to before an
election Tom Hartman what have we been
watching that was David bossy he was the
president of citizens united and which
produced a hit piece movie on Hillary
Clinton I think David would probably
describe it that way to it and and they
were going to play it within the 90-day
window when the Federal Election
Commission said you can't do political
activity frightening it within those 90
days prior to an election he took that
case to the Supreme Court and won the
Supreme Court ruled court yes we
affirmed corporations are people going
back to 1886 we affirm the 1976 buckley
versus vallejo decision that that
spending money on politics prior to 76
1976 it was considered a behavior which
could be regulated since 1976 that
Supreme Court case that Lois Powell was
very instrumental to making that happen
it has been considered a protected First
Amendment free speech and and I think
that you know time has proven me out I
mean you know look at look at the donald
trump is agreeing with me right now
right now they're all owned by the rich
people are the big corporations marco
rubio has
zone personal billionaire who has been
responsible for virtually his entire
political career Jeb Bush I'm sure has
many and not to mention family riches
you can just kind of go through the list
and when they lose their billionaires or
when they lose their billionaire backing
they have to bail out and and to some
extent this happens on the Democratic
side as well the notable exception right
now being Bernie Sanders which is
fascinating you talk to Bernie Sanders
on a regular basis don't ya when I lived
in Vermont he came on our program and
took calls and it was so novel to have a
member of Congress a sitting member of
the House representatives who would take
calls unfiltered unscreened I mean my
wife was a call screener at that time
Boies and basically all we looked for in
terms of not letting people on the air
was people who were drunker who were
profane you know they call up swearing
or they sounded drunk they didn't get on
but other than and Bernie just started
taking these calls and for an hour and
we called it brunch with Bernie and we
did we've been doing it now since 2004 I
think every Friday and it was it it was
amazing to me to discover a politician
who never biessed us you know never
tried to never tried to do this slick
you know oh you know when the wave old
words you know the weasel words all that
kind of stuff if he believes something
he would say here's what I believe if he
didn't know the answer he'd say I don't
know the answer I frequently say I'll
find out he come back next week and say
hey somebody called last week and want
to know about this and I'm just amazed
impressed
and by senator Sanders but you
interviewed Dave bossy yeah do you often
interview people that you don't agree
with more often than I interview people
with whom I do agree yeah yeah it's I
think that talk radio basically there's
there's a couple of different categories
of ways that you can do radio and this
goes back to some of the early articles
that I was writing when I was just
playing with the idea of doing it one is
the guest driven show
and you know which is popular it's more
popular in television than radio but the
problem with a guest driven show is that
the show is only as good as its guests
and you can't always get great gifts you
can have a caller driven show but then
your show is only as good as your
callers you can have a news driven show
which is basically what CNN does and
they're what look at what happens when
you have a crisis their ratings go up
and when you don't they fall in the tank
or you can have a host driven show and
in the modern era Rush Limbaugh really
invented that genre and so when we put
our show together we decided that it
would be a host driven show because I
knew radio and I knew my topics and so
most of the radio show is just me
talking to the listeners and and then
you know there's the old adage people
slow down for fistfights and car wrecks
that you want to make it entertaining
you want to make it interesting and I
actually respect most of the people on
the other side who I debate
my father was an Eisenhower Republican
Republican activist Goldwater Republican
wasn't when I was 13 years old in 1964
my dad and I went door-to-door for Barry
Goldwater in my heart I knew he was
right I had read John Stormers book none
dare call it treason the year earlier
and I was convinced that the State
Department was filled with communists
and that we were going to go down the
tubes this was it and three years later
I the Vietnam War in large part I think
completely changed my political
perspective then from the time I was 16
until my dad died in 2006 he and I
fought like cats and dogs about politics
and after the first couple of years I
mean he actually threw me out of the
house over a political argument when one
night when I was 16 but after a couple
years we figured out how to do this
without hurting our relationship and my
dad was my political foil throughout my
life he died a Republican in fact the
his two favorite pictures when my father
was dying in his living room my brothers
and I and a couple their wives always
were sitting with him and as he was
drawing his last breath I was sitting
there with my hand on his shoulder and I
looked across the bed that was in the
living room now and there on the wall
where these two pictures
me shaking hands with Pope John Paul the
second and George W Bush on the aircraft
carrier Abraham Lincoln declaring
mission accomplished and those R is you
know that that was my dad you know and
so I discovered I learned that you can
have a knock-down drag-out with somebody
and still respect them and love them
even and so that's become sort of a
trademark of both my radio and TV show
is to is to bring on both sides I also
think it's good for our viewers and
listeners because they get to hear both
sides of the argument you know I gave it
bossy saying you know I want more speech
well that's fine you know we all want
more speech but to say the American
people are smart enough to figure out
you know to the see through lies in
advertising for example if that was true
then the industry that I I owned to ad
agencies here is the industry that I
worked in for the better part of the
decade would not exist I mean you know
if advertising didn't work nobody would
be doing it and we'd have a completely
different media model completely
different business model the fact of the
matter is that advertising does change
people's minds and if you spend a
billion dollars on advertising you will
produce a shift in opinion and whether
that should be done solely by and for
the benefit of very wealthy individuals
and large corporations in the political
sphere or not is my fundamental
disagreement with David and and and with
Scalia and you know the others on the
court who who voted for Citizens United
what's your reputation amongst
conservatives a I'm not altogether
certain I know a number of them on I
know and like and I'm friends with
there's a couple of conservative
websites that love to do hit pieces on
me too one a couple days ago that was
actually they were two in the last week
one was actually pretty pretty
straightforward pretty honest you know I
had senator Whitehouse had called for
corporations that fund climate denial to
be prosecuted under the RICO Act the
same way that the tobacco companies were
prosecuted in 1999 under the RICO Act
funding denial that tobacco causes
cancer or is addictive and that was a
successful prosecution by the 2006 the
tobacco companies had to admit yep we
engaged in crime and so I went on the
air and you know debating with a
conservative who was defending climate
change denial and saying you know if
you're one of these guys who's like
putting up the money and hiring the
people and getting the message out
that's organized crime under the RICO
statutes you should be in jail and they
did a piece on this and I thought you
know okay they were criticizing me for
it
but it was an honest portrayal then a
couple days later somebody else you know
in the conservative media did a long hit
piece on me where they took a logic
chain that I went through on the air and
deleted the entire middle of it it was
just a completely dishonest hit piece so
the first one I talked about on the air
I credited the author I mean you know
he's like PT Barnum said as long as you
spell my name right the second one
though I just ignored I but I think I
think what they're willing to come on
your show oh yeah yeah regularly and
many of them in over many years I've got
know so many of them quite well from
your book cracking the code a note to
the reader this book is written in a new
language every word means precisely what
it says the tools of communication
revealed herein are also used in its
writings and you go on to say that my
aim with this book is to give you the
tools to tell the liberal story and tell
it well yeah that that book started out
as a book about neuro linguistic
programming NLP which is a construct for
communication and but it was a political
year as I recall I wrote that in 2001
for or 2008 while the other we ferment
into second day I was one of the
presidential years and maybe it was one
of the inner interstitial years but
whatever I wanted it to be a political
hand guide 407 for Democrats yes so this
is for the 2008 election and that's why
it's called cracking the code
understanding you know how not only how
language works but how to use language
successful what's an example what the
classic example is Frank once renaming
the estate tax as the death tax you know
it completely shifts the frame pretty
effective there wasn't it was and
continues to be and it didn't come out
until much later that a lot of the early
research into what kind of wording would
cause people to turn against the estate
tax was funded by the walton airs and to
the tune of some of fair amount of money
and that was affected this Facebook
comment this is from Philip Tommy were
simply the best you can tell you have
done your homework my question is will
Americans vote for a Jewish Democratic
Socialist senior citizen who by most
educated people's estimation would make
America great again yeah I respond to
that question with a question which was
posed to me in the fall of 2007 by I
believe the number-two guy in the
Democratic Party in California he might
have been just the number-two guy in the
Democratic Party down in Los Angeles but
whatever and he was african-american any
chemo my program and he said this is
when Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama
were fighting it out and he said nobody
in America at the end of the day you
know we can talk all we like about our
first black president all this kind of
stuff but nobody is going to vote for a
guy who has only been in the Senate for
two years has basically very little
experience in this field he's African
American and his middle name is Hussein
it ain't gonna happen this was an
african-american Democrat saying this on
my program and he was like you know we
have to get out there and he says I want
to talk to the black community we have
to support Hillary Clinton because
Barack Obama there's no way he's going
to become president and yeah you know
guess who's president so I I think it's
entirely possible that America will vote
for a 70 something Jewish senator with a
New York accent because what he's saying
is right and
you know this is the thing I learned in
Vermont when I lived in Vermont for ten
years and if you go up and drive around
the Northeast Kingdom which is the most
conservative part the most rural part of
Vermont it's solidly red and you drive
along the road and you will see in the
election year the number 2000 the
election year there would be a bush for
president sign and a Bernie for Congress
sign next to each other in lawn after
lon after lon Bernie consistently
carries in the neighborhood of 20
percent of the Republican vote in
Vermont he was re-elected with you the
71 or 74 percent of the total vote to
the Senate and Vermont is not you know a
hippie Haven solid blue state the two
largest cities are Burlington Montpelier
but you get outside those two cities and
you are looking at in a red state rural
conservative Republican country and they
have embraced brain because he's a truth
teller
his radical truth though why'd you move
to Washington we moved to Washington DC
five years ago there was a an
opportunity to do a TV program on the RT
network which is owned by the Russians
and it's there they wanted to get into
the put an orc or into the water of Al
Jazeera and CNN International and BBC
and all that and and I said you know we
I've always owned by own show I won't
become an employee I have to have
absolute editorial control by contract
and if you're willing to go along with
those terms which I'd had this
conversation earlier with one of the big
cable networks here in the United States
and they were unwilling to do that they
were like you're an employee you will do
what we say or not or eat or you won't
work here Artie said no we'll give you
your own show or will will carry your
show it's also carried by free speech TV
and so you know it was it was something
fun you know it was my my a DD I guess
you know I was bored let's try something
new
and that show is still on the air so
I've got 7:00 and 10:00 p.m.
yes it was a wire show runs at 7:00 p.m.
on RT and it runs at 10 p.m. on free
speech TV and you're ready to show the
radio show is noon to 3:00 Eastern Time
Sirius XM it's on radio stations around
the country it's also simulcast as
television by free speech TV on dish and
direct and a number of cable systems and
you can listen to tom hartman.com as
well you can find yeah and you can find
links to all that stuff there and
however you spell it we'll get you there
we've got all four misspellings no Tom
Hartman is our guest let's take some
calls we're going to begin with a call
from David in the Hobe Sound actually
Murray in San Diego California hi Murray
you're on with Tom Hartman hi thank you
very much I'm so delighted that mr.
Hartman is on the air I am a volunteer
with a community radio station in San
Diego knsj networking for social justice
and we carry mr. Hartman's and show and
were so grateful that we're able to
bring it to a San Diego audience where
the political climate is changing from a
very conservative population to going to
more liberal so and we really appreciate
the brunch with Bernie and the different
guests that mr. Hartman branks brings on
I have three questions in light of the
most recent shooting I'm wondering if
there is something in the DNA in America
that we for celebrities and others if we
hear something we don't like that there
are death threats secondly I wonder if I
keep hearing that people have short
attention spans and we're talking about
some of our programming on our community
radio station about the length of
coverage that we give some things and I
I disagree I see I credit people with
being more interested than just trying
to encapsulate things that I was
wondering how mr. Hartman feels and
earlier he was talking if I want Laurie
we're going to leave it there because we
got a lot of caller
on hold any response for that caller mr.
Hartman sure first of all with regard to
shooting I don't think that there's
anything unique in the American DNA that
causes us to disproportionately murder
each other with guns I agree with
President Obama that we are washing guns
and so somebody who is crazy or violent
or angry or suicidal let's remember gun
suicides are one of the biggest causes
of death by guns in the United States if
you can just reach over grab a gun Oh
bang like that it's like hey it's over
fast or you know this young man who shot
up Roseburg Oregon
you know if you've got 15 guns you know
you can do a lot of damage so as
President Obama pointed out we have no
more or no fewer crazy people in the
United States and they do in France or
Germany or the United Kingdom they're
Australia or anyplace else what we do
have the difference between US and all
those other countries is that in those
countries if you're a sports shooter you
have to be licensed in some of them
insured and your gun is registered and
or if you're a hunter or if you want a
gun for personal protection and I've
always advocated that that we should
treat guns the way we did cars you know
back back in the 19-teens when cars
started becoming ubiquitous and also
started killing people the problem was
what do we do with these things they're
killing people and so we came up with
standards you know red like yellow light
green light and those kind of things but
one of the most important standards that
we came up with is if you're going to
drive a car you have to a prove that
you're proficient you know how to do it
safely if it have a driver's license B
you have to have liability insurance so
if you injure somebody else
intentionally or unintentionally they
are covered and see the car has to be
registered from the time of manufactured
all the time of destruction with a chain
of ownership the liability insurance I
think is one of the most important ones
and this is this is something that I
would think that conservatives would
embrace because it's a market-based
solution if you have to have liability
insurance
to own a gun it probably wouldn't be
particularly expensive it might be fifty
bucks a year 100 bucks a year but if
you've got three DUIs I'm guessing that
the insurance actuaries or a conviction
for domestic violence or you robbed a
liquor store three years ago I'm
guessing that those actuaries would go
okay this guy's price is going to be
four thousand dollars a year for his
liability insurance and so what you
would see is the marketplace putting
pressure on just like they do with drunk
drivers you know with the car insurance
companies they jack up your insurance
rates and so I that's where I would
start actually along with closing the
gun show loopholes and things like that
but I don't think there's anything
unique about us except that were awash
in guns number one and with the regard
to the wall-to-wall coverage which we've
been watching for the last couple days
yeah I agree I kept track of Louise and
I were watching I think was MSNBC the
other day and the host was slowly
painfully you know we don't know yeah
all this guy and I'm like can't you say
in other news around the world you know
let's go now to the to the refugee
crisis in Europe let's let's talk about
you or something you know I did but but
we live in if it bleeds it leads world
it's all about ratings it's all about
making money which it didn't used to be
when I was doing news in the 70s I
because of the Fairness Doctrine which
did not require if you've got a liberal
on you've got to have a conservative on
that's a canard the the essence of the
Fairness Doctrine was that your license
will not be renewed if you do not
program in the public interest and the
principal way that radio and television
stations program in the public interest
was by carrying news and as a news
reporter in a local station and our news
division lost money for witl there was
like four or five of us working in news
that was that was the license for the
station and in 87 Reagan stopped
enforcement of the Fairness Doctrine and
within six months CBS had moved their
news there vice president of news
is over to work under the vice-president
of entertainment and turned their news
division into a profit-making thing and
within a year the other two networks
have done the same and now it's all
profits news for profit and that's why
we have infotainment rather than real
news Franklin and that's why the news
will obsess on a particular topic
because they think that that's going to
draw the most eyeballs
now Thom Hartmann I'm flipping through
all your books because I remember
reading that you don't think that a
Fairness Doctrine is necessary for radio
yeah
I don't think that the way that the
Fairness Doctrine was characterized and
and to some extent you know like if a
television station editorialized and
said you know we think Bernie Sanders a
terrible guy then the Fairness Doctrine
required that after that editorial
somebody come on who would say no Bernie
Sanders is a decent guy but that was
about it
and it was principled and back in the
day radio and TV stations used to do
editorials and so it was some balance in
that but in terms of guests now I you
know I see nothing wrong with a station
carrying conservative or progressive
programming all day long I don't want
the government involved in telling us
how to program I think that the role of
government historically is sort of like
the role of the NFL you know there we've
got the game of politics you've got the
game of business these are basically you
know activities that we participate
football game and the NFL says okay
here's our hundred yards on the field
here are the rules
here's the punishment for breaking the
rules you know they define the rules of
the game and the rules of the game prior
to 87 were defined in a way that
encouraged actual news and encouraged a
well-educated populous since 87 the
rules in visitin of the game in news
anyway have been completely changed so
now it is we get the news that makes the
most profit for the people delivering
the news to us whether that's the fact
that you know NBC also owns NBC
Universal so instead of news tonight
we're going to talk with the movie star
of the latest Universal movie or
whatever you know is it's just and not
to pick on NBC I mean any day everybody
does this I don't I don't think it
serves our democracy
well Sean and battleground Washington
please go ahead with your question or
comment for Tom Hartman Tom it's almost
been 30 years since Michael Moore made
his documentary Roger and me then he
also went on to make Bowling for
Columbine and the point he made it there
was that it's not about gun control
it's about our miserly social safety net
how most other industrialized countries
have far more generous social safety
nuts it just seems that we witnessed
this slow-motion train wreck of class
war in this country with the destruction
of the middle class and the cheaters are
prospering no one has been punished and
sent to jail for the wall street
takedown of the economy the same can be
said for the invasion and occupation of
Iraq Richard Wolff is a regular guest on
your show and he makes the point that
Americans no longer have any leverage
against the plutocracy we're not needed
as workers with the free trade
agreements we're not needed as consumers
as new markets are opened up overseas
could you please talk about the
taft-hartley Act and the Paul memo and
how Americans no longer have any
leverage to fight back against Wall
Street and go Bernie
okay thanks taft-hartley was well back
up a little bit prior to 1935 you had
unions were not did not have federal
protection and so if you were unionizing
in a company that was that hired the
Pinkertons or other strike buster groups
you had a really good chance of being
killed and a lot of people died in the
union movement particularly between the
1870s when we really began to
industrialize the United States in
nineteen in the 1930s with the Wagner
Act in 1935 the National Labor Relations
Act unions became legal and protected
your right to unionize was protected
unions are a democracy in the workplace
and therefore I think very important to
the workplace in 1946 for the first time
since nineteen percent since the
election of 1932 the Republicans took
of Congress for two years and they
passed the taft-hartley Act which blew a
big hole in the side of the Wagner Act
of the National Labor Relations Act that
allowed individual states to basically
opt out of the union protections of the
Wagner Act and becomes so-called right
to work
I call it right to work for less states
and this was largely confined to the
deep south for most of our history since
47 although now you know Scott Walker
did it in Wisconsin John Kasich and
Indiana I think Rick Snyder in Michigan
I'd have to go back and look but this
was the beginning of the war on labor on
working people in the United States and
then it really wowed steroids of the
Reagan administration if you look at the
history of productivity and workers
wages from the George Washington
administration to the Ronald Reagan
administration those two numbers kind of
climbed in concert with each other as
workers were more productive in some
cases of the result of mechanization but
his workers made more money for their
employers they made more money
themselves and then in 1981 you see
these lines diverge and productivity
continues to go up and wages flattened
out and wages right now are actually
below where they were in 1980 when
Reagan when Reagan was elected in 81
when he came into office and you know
this is the natural consequence I think
of that Louis Powell in 71 and the
Palmetto in response in large part to
Ralph Nader and Rachel Carlson fact he
talked about in the Pala memo
unsafe at any speed in Silent Spring he
said these books have created consumer
movements and these consumers are trying
to regulate our businesses and trying to
politicize our businesses and we need to
fight back
traditionally business has not been
political business needs to become
political we need to set up think tanks
we set up an organization that will
eventually take over the judiciary of
the United States we need to take over
Congress we need to take control the
political parties we need to gain
control over the media to the extent
posit you know you went through this
list and in my book the crash in 2016 I
summarize the Pala memo and there's a
whole chapter about Lewis Powell
palmela in there because I see that as
kind of the starting point of the modern
crash right now it's the deregulation of
the American banking industry that FDR
had put into place in 35 along with a
whole bunch of other industries so
between that and so-called free trade
where we are basically the only country
in the in the developed world that no
longer protects our workers used to be
everybody gated with tariffs this was
proposed by Alexander Hamilton 1791 in
his report on manufacturers it was
adopted in large part by Congress or by
executive action by 1793 and tariffs
which are taxes on imported goods is
what Donald Trump talks about when he
says you know if Ford wants to build a
car factory in Mexico fine let them but
when that car hits the border there'll
be a 35% tax on it coming into the
United States
that's called a tariff tariffs provided
100 percent of the revenue that
supported the federal government the
United States from 1787 when we
officially started as a country until
until the Civil War five percent from
the Civil War to World War one there
were two thirds of total federal revenue
between two thirds and three quarters
and declined over that from World War
one to World War two it was fully a
third of our federal revenue and during
that period of time and right up until
the 80s you know our average tariff
rates fluctuated in the neighborhood of
20 to 30 percent and so you know the
theory was is Hamilton laid out was you
know if you can make a pair of shoes in
Connecticut where the dollars where the
labor or you can make that pair of shoes
in Mexico 50 cents for the labor or in
China with 20 cents worth of Labor
then when the shoes come in from Mexico
we're going to hit them with a 50 cent
tax when they come in from China we're
going to hit them with an 80 cent tax so
it's going to cost you the same to make
the shoes anywhere in the world you
might as well make them here you don't
pay for shipping and so we used to make
sure this here we used to make blue
jeans and we used to make clothing and
we used to make chairs and now we don't
make any of that stuff or very little of
it because it's you know because we did
away with our tariffs other countries
the other developed countries if you
look at China at Taiwan which arguably
is developing country but Taiwan South
Korea Japan all of the European
countries
they had in the background something
that they could use when they said oh
we'll all join the WTO and drop our
tariffs right so our tariffs the US
average tariffs now are around 2% so
we've all dropped our tariffs so they
use their vat tax value-added tax as a
tariff as a functional tariff but we
have VAT tax works is every time you add
value to a manufactured good you pay a
small tax so when iron ore is mined and
smelted into pig iron pay a small tax
take that pig iron converted into steel
a small tax convert that steel into
rolled steel pay a small tax computer
that rolled steel into a card or pay a
small tax convert the card or into a car
pay a small tax and sew it with Germany
for example the average VAT tax on a car
is around 17 percent and German
taxpayers pay that so the way that they
use this and all these countries are
doing this except us were they're like
the village idiots I'm I find myself
channeling Donald Trump way more than I
would like to in any case but he's right
on these things the the what they do is
they say okay if you want to ship a
Mercedes from Germany to the United
States we're going to give you a 17
percent reimbursement at that tax
because you're not a German so that's a
subsidized export on the other hand if
you want to take an American car and
sell it in Germany we're going to put a
17 percent VAT tax on it when it enters
our country because our cars have a 17
percent tax that's functionally an
import tariff and when you combine the
two you've got you know at the weather
37 38 percent whatever 17 plus 17 is at
34 percent functional tariffs you know
in both directions and that's why all
these countries are running huge trade
surpluses and we're running six to eight
hundred billion dollar-a-year trade
deficit and and and it really flipped in
the 80s when Reagan came into office in
1981 we were the world's largest
creditor more countries owed us money
than any other country in the history of
the world we imported raw materials we
imported iron ore we imported wood and
we manufactured things out of it and we
were the world's largest importer of raw
materials and the world's largest
exporter of finished goods these are
real at that I mean
that's a sign of a healthy economy and
we and we had a net positive trade
balance so you know we were accumulating
money coming from other countries and so
we were investing in those other
countries which some people decried as
neo colonialism but whatever by the end
of the George the Herbert Walker Bush
administration basically the end of the
Reagan era we had become the world's
largest debtor we had become the world's
largest importer of finished goods and
the world's largest exporter of raw
materials so now we ship coal and iron
ore and wood to China and they ship us
back computers and and furniture and I
mean you name it right and and then we
owe them I think our trade deficit with
China right now is in the neighborhood
of 200 billion dollars a year and the
consequence of this is that now 1/7 of
all assets in the United States are
owned by foreigners because you know if
you end up with the rest of the world is
ending up every year with roughly 600
billion dollars in surplus dollars
because we borrowed from the Chinese and
bought their stuff we got the stuff they
got the dollars where do you spend
dollars here ultimately and so you know
a couple nights ago I was at UN for the
General Assembly and we had a dare in
the waldorf-astoria guess what it just
got bought by the Chinese so it's not
that I'm trying to promote xenophobia
but I just don't think it's a good thing
when 1/7 of your country is no longer
owned by by your country men and women
so anyway long response I think but call
or ask me what title was and I told her
how to build a clock or him from your
book rebooting the American Dream 11
ways to rebuild our country you listed
here Alexander Hamilton's 11 point plan
for American manufacturers those
strategic proposals built the greatest
industrial powerhouse the world had ever
seen and after more than 200 successful
years or abandoned only during the
administration's of Ronald Reagan George
HW Bush and Bill Clinton and remain
abandoned
this day that's again here's the cover
of the book rebooting the American Dream
if that is something you're interested
in reading about this text for you Tom
Hartman why is citizens united not okay
that unions are entirely political also
should unions be taxed thirty five
percent like corporations interesting
questions first of all unions are not
for profit organizations so they don't
generate a profit so there would be
nothing to tax
secondly the the confluence of citizens
united in unions I'm guessing the
question was should unions be able to
run ads in favor of or opposed to
candidates the same as General Electric
can or David and Charles Koch can or one
of their front groups you know Freedom
Works or and my answer that is no I
don't think that any corporation and
unions are corporations even though
they're nonprofit corporations I don't
think that any corporation should have
rights guaranteed under our Constitution
of quote free political speech and and I
think that that would work to the
benefit of unions actually if we were to
say we're going to reverse Citizens
United
and not just for corporations but for
unions as well by the way taft-hartley
in 1947 limited unions political
activity dramatically and and right now
if you pay union dues if you're in a
union you there's two things that you
pay that Union and I'm a member of
sag-aftra I'm real familiar with us and
my my dad was you know it worked in a
union machine shop for forty years two
of my brothers have been union shop
stewards and printing union the IBEW the
heard the yeah Electrical Workers you
pay the union dues which basically pay
for the lawyers who represent you if
you're in a dispute with your employer
the negotiators who negotiate your pay
package those kind of things and then
you can also pay into the unions
political action fund function we know
is typically not called that but that's
what they are that second category of
payments
are voluntary you can simply in some
cases opt out in other cases you have to
opt in but you can say to the Union you
may not use my money for politics and
I'm not going to give you that extra
money to use for politics and you know a
lot of people do that and I you know I
frankly I don't have a big problem with
that so I think unions should be
representing their workers if the but
the way that if this would benefit
unions is that if we were to say AT&T
and the Union both can't engage in
political activity anymore they can't
they can't be they can't own a
congressman their favorite congressman
and they can't you know run television
advertising so now the president of AT&T
sends a letter to all of his employees
saying we think that Romney is the best
presidential candidate we really like
him you should get out and help him
what's the average employee going to do
the president says I should do this you
know that's not going to influence me on
the other hand a union is a democracy it
takes a 50% vote of the employees to
create the Union a 50% vote can dissolve
the Union and if the union is going to
take any political position it has to be
a majority the majority vote and so when
the union holds an election to decide
who are we going to represent what are
we going to do or asks their members
what should we do and you see this right
now with a couple of unions that are
debating whether to endorse Hillary or
Bernie for example is a huge battle
going on in a couple of Union or Donald
Trump yeah around this around this when
when that happens the Union even if they
don't put a penny into that campaign you
now have the union member if a union
sends out a letter dollar membership
saying 51% or 60% or 70% of our members
just decided that we're going to endorse
like with National Nurses United their
membership endorsed Bernie the the Lord
what I think it's the largest mostly
women union in the United States and
it's also one of the larger unions
announces and even if they don't spend a
penny in the political world they now
have probably at least half of their
members who are willing to show up and
help out they'll walk you know
do what my dad and I did in 64 for barry
goldwater they'll go door-to-door and
share the message with people and things
like that because it's democracy because
it's it's a group you know that is
interested that is there for each other
rather than there for just the employer
for example next call for time yes some
noises coming out of the ceiling here in
the ranch fan will just keep moving
adrian is in houston texas
adrian thanks for holding you're on with
author and talk show host Tom Hartman
thank you my brother lives in California
he talks about Tom all the time so I'm
glad to talk to him when he mentioned
glass-steagall I was so grateful because
Elizabeth Warren is the only person that
I've seen that even brought this up and
when the crash happened in 2008 that's
the first thing that came to my mind
glass-steagall that was a slippery slope
I feel like you know what happened to us
and I wonder does he think we will ever
see a facsimile of glass-steagall will
we ever see anything like it and let's
not leave NAFTA out of this I messed up
the economy and so it also makes me
think you know what Democrats and
Republicans why the electorate is mad
all of us because we don't feel like
there's a dimes worth of difference yeah
last glass-steagall for people who don't
know what we're talking about here in
the in the early 30s and it was either
33 or 35 the glass-steagall Act
separated Investment Banking from retail
banking one of the things that provoked
the great crash and made it so bad that
the week that Franklin Roosevelt became
president every bank in the United
States failed it was which is an amazing
thing when you think about it the reason
was so bad is that banks were also
casinos they were they were running
stock gambling operations and everybody
was getting in on it you know leading up
to the great crash of 29 and so when the
gambling operations went down the
checkbook savings operation went down
the paten you know the all those kind of
things my mother's family was fairly
prominent in the in the 20s and they
lost everything in the crash of 29
because the bank that had all their
money just said sorry we don't have your
money anymore it's gone we're closing
our doors and this happened to millions
of Americans and so what glass-steagall
did was it said that boring banking
business which is basically the
lubrication for an economy the ability
to have a checking account a savings
account and get business loans a
mortgage that is now going to be done in
one area of banking that's the
old-fashioned boring you know bankers
hours banking it's predictable
predictably moderately profitable but
it's basically boring and the gambling
stuff you want to engage in the stock
market go to a brokerage house go to to
a quote bank that you know is an
investment bank and so you had the rise
of the Merrill Lynch's and you had the
rise of the bank banks and they were
kept separate from thirty-five as I
recall right up until either 99 or 2000
when Ken Lay of Enron wanted he was he
was there were two things he wanted he
wanted to be able to speculate in energy
as if it was a commodity and he couldn't
any and he wanted to be able to get the
bank's off his back he had 800 different
holding companies and he was shifting
money around to make this company look
profitable in this company you know
hiding his losses and the banks were
starting to catch on to him so he wanted
to own his own Bank and Wendy Gramm had
been on his board of directors for
number of years she was the wife of Phil
Gramm the senator from Texas Phil Gramm
introduced legislation to do this to do
what in my opinion what Ken Lay wanted
in two pieces of legislation one was the
Commodity Futures Modernization Act
which led to basically the deregulation
of commodities and led to this whole
derivative thing that I think we were
talking about earlier and the second was
gramm-leach-bliley which repealed the
glass-steagall Act and the argument that
that Graham and his allies made was you
know this glass-steagall Act has kept us
from having a banking crisis ever since
1935 it's done its work it's time to
retire it and I think if he had made
that argument in 1950 or 1960 on the
floor of the Senate when there were
senators who were alive in 1929 they
would have laughed him off if they did
run him out with a pitchfork but because
you know as Arnold Toynbee says you know
when the last man who remembers the
horrors of the last great war dies the
next great war becomes inevitable you
know we don't remember the the genesis
of the awful stuff so you know pretty
much everybody was dead who remember the
great crash in 1999 and so Congress
passed and blew up glass-steagall and
the banks and the and the gambling
houses merged and we're right back where
we were in 1929 which is something that
we need to do something about senator
Sanders is called for a reinstatement of
glass-steagall as has a little Warren
and I think we need to do that it's very
important I don't remember her second
point I'm sorry do you Peter no we're
going to move on our end we'll get this
question from fran in los angeles
what one book written by you or anyone
else gives the best information on
income inequality this is a text
probably screwed screwed is a book that
I wrote some years back about the plight
of the middle class in the United States
and how we got here and although the
crash of 2016 has a lot of that material
in it as well but in screwed I tried to
get back to first principles I mean I
went all the way back to to the origin
of economies in the origin of democracy
Thomas Hobbes John Locke Rousseau Thomas
Jefferson you know the Enlightenment and
right up to today that would be the book
John and West Palm Beach Florida please
go ahead with your question or comment
for author Tom Hartman good afternoon I
always keep waiting an hour because then
there's so many other questions I want
to ask just a few comments if I may I
grew up in a Democratic household and my
father belonged to the International
Brotherhood of Electrical Workers and
now I am a flaming conservative I always
loved the Margaret Thatcher quote that
says that social livens socialism is
great until you run out of other
people's money as far as the you know
the right to spend money for elections I
mean that's critical thinking it's not
taught anymore I was taught critical
thinking growing up in the 60s you're
making the argument that we could that
that if somebody runs an ad on
television that says hey if you take
this pill it'll cure you over this and
doesn't tell you that oh by the way it
might also cause that that we can
critically think our way out of being
lied to in a television ad you haven't
been seeing those commercials don't you
don't you see all that little fine print
and the guy talking a thousand miles a
minute you might hear your eyes might
pop out and your arms might fall off and
we need to call your doctor immediately
anyway driving is a privilege not a
right actually
article 1 section 8 of the Constitution
authorizes Congress to build roads it's
in the Constitution what I has nothing
to do with driving I mean come on a
carriage did they have licenses to drive
a horse and buggy back then the right to
bear arms is in the Constitution also ok
so that's in order to maintain a
well-regulated militia
I thought I thought I could be friendly
with you saying that I was you know
racing a democratic council I mean I
thought we were going to get off on the
right foot here but anyway my question
to you is and I'll give you a clue on
from Danbury Connecticut and I'd like to
read you something real quickly the
quote is and extracting the pure
principles which Jesus taught we should
have to strip off the artificial
vestments in which they have been
muffled there will be found remaining
the most sublime and benevolent code of
morals which has ever been offered to
man now that's a letter from Thomas
Jefferson in 1813 to John Adams yeah now
I'm not saying that Jefferson was the
greatest Christian of all time and he'll
read the Jefferson Bible I know he cut
out what he wanted to that's funny cut
out all the miracles he did not believe
that Jesus was divine he cut out all the
miracles that book is still in print by
the way ok but you know how do you
explain the quote I just gave you all
right John we're going to John we're
going to leave it there thanks for
calling in thanks for participating
today mr. Hartman it you know it's it's
true that Jesus taught moral principles
it's also true that these are part of
our DNA that as a species altruism is
natural to us in six six month old
babies you see them unhappy when one
baby is
given more than another baby in their
presence you know fairness is in our DNA
altruism is in our DNA
socialism is in our DNA for lack of a
better way of saying it there are there
are tribes all over the world that have
never heard of Jesus that live in a very
altruistic fashion and always have in
fact this was one of the things the most
amazed me reading Jefferson's works was
when he was a child his father was a
surveyor in Virginia and at the time
probably 8090 percent of Virginia was
Indian Territory and his father spoke
five different Indian languages
Jefferson spoke a couple of them and he
would travel with his father when he was
out surveying these Indian territories
and he was he would live with it with
Native Americans and he was so impressed
by their high moral character and he
writes about over and over and over
again he actually at one point dances
around the edge of you know thinking
that maybe the Native Americans who were
actually genetically superior to the
white Europeans this is an era when the
genetic security already of white
Europeans over African Americans was
used as the excuse for slavery so you
know it's stuff that we would laugh at
now or be disgusted by but but in any
case he was just so impressed by the
Native Americans so you know saying
something nice about Jesus does not make
one a Christian and Jefferson was very
clear that the frauds of the clergy is
who referred to it probably 40 or 50
times in his various letters were one of
the big crises that could face America
Jefferson and Madison had a series of
really interesting letters in eighteen
in 1787 when Jefferson was the envoy to
France and Madison was helping write the
Constitution and Madison was Jefferson's
protege they were very close friends and
and Madison was 20 years younger and
Madison was as I recall a Presbyterian
it might have been a Congregationalist
but he was a Christian and Jefferson was
a deist openly not a Christian deists
believed that some intelligence brought
the universe into being and then just
step back but
quote God doesn't interfere with beta
day life but that everything came out of
something that is sacred and divine so a
deist would see the world and see it is
alive and sacred but would not pray to
anybody to do anything
intercessory prayer which is not part of
deism so anyhow Jefferson and Madison
had this correspondence where Madison
was concerned that if government ever
started subsidizing churches and or even
providing them with very specific
protections and this turned into a quite
a discussion around the First Amendment
that the churches would become corrupted
and Madison was very concerned about
Christianity he did not want it to be
corrupted by government Jefferson on the
other hand was concerned about a priest
becoming president or a member of
Congress he thought that members of the
clergy should should be essentially
banned from political service I mean he
never came out specifically for a ban
but he was very worried about that he
was very concerned that religion would
corrupt government
so his government 'got corrupt religion
or is religion in a corrupt government
and Madison got his see I told you so
during the first couple of weeks of his
new presidency in of 18 every year he
became president 1809 as I recall he
vetoed up until that point George
Washington had put into place the first
welfare program in the United States it
was to pay for the poor houses in
Washington DC to pay for medical care
housing clothing and food for poor
people for the paupers and the federal
government paid for this directly from
the George Washington administration
through the Jefferson through Adams and
Jefferson administration and then in the
first weeks of Adams administration
Congress passed a law saying that that
money would be routed through the
churches and the churches would take
over this function because it's a
Christian function and that was James
Madison's first veto and he said no we
are not going to give federal money to
churches they will corrupt the churches
and this will establish a precedent and
you use the word precedent this will
establish a precedent of corrupting
these churches not going to happen so
now we look back at this kind of naive
debate that they were having about which
is more dangerous you know the church is
taking over government or influencing
government
we're a government funding the churches
and most making them changing their
essential nature and character both of
happened so Tom Hartland is our guest
David is in Hobe Sound Florida David
please go ahead hi good afternoon
Peter hey Dana sorry I missed you when I
was in Washington anyway anyhow two
things number one at the beginning of
the program mr. Hartman you mentioned
that you were started your talk show in
reaction to Fox and talk radio well you
know talk radio and Fox I didn't came
into existence in reaction to NBC CBS
and ABC having a monopoly on news
distribution from the left so let's
let's go back to the beginning
all right that's number one number two
I'd like you to contrast how
conservative speakers are treated on
campus these days with the way Bernie
Sanders was treated at Liberty
University not exactly a bastion of
leftism when he spoke there and I think
that gives you a good insight that those
two that contrast gives you a good
insight to how liberals act these days
okay mr. Hartman not sure what the
question was but it's a nice creation
story about the creation of Fox News I
don't I don't think it's accurate and
but but or you could say you know if you
really think that facts are liberal then
yeah the news is all liberal and so you
know if you want to promote something
that's not facts you know like hey let's
let's pretend that the climate is not
warming up you know let's pretend that
tobacco doesn't cause addiction or
cancer let's that which was you know a
generation ago but these kind of
conservative positions let's pretend
that the war in Vietnam was a wonderful
thing
you know if you want to have your own
facts and they're not really facts fine
I think that one of the reasons why
liberals generally do better on college
campuses than conservatives is because
many of the conservative positions are
basically anti science anti fact we try
and claim that the world is 6,000 years
old try to try to deny a global global
climate change and and and global
warming and the science behind that
these the Republican Party in the United
States is the only political party in
the world in the world that says the
global warming isn't happening
talk to the Conservatives and I've done
it I went to Denmark spent spent a week
there on Danish radio interviewed the
top conservative politicians in that
country and I'd say okay you're you're
conservative you must be you must deny
the global warming is happening no no we
know what's happening we got to do
something about all your conservative
you must hate the national health care
system here the national single-payer
health care oh no I don't want to do
away with that oh you're conservative
you most you must want to do away with
the fact that when people want to go to
college in Denmark they actually get a
$200 a month stipend and tuition is free
you know to help pay for books and rent
and think oh no I wouldn't I wouldn't do
so then what makes your conservative and
invariably the answer was we don't want
any more immigrants that was that's the
you know if you're a conservative in
Europe you're basically anti-immigrant
the other the other thing that concerns
me frankly increasingly is that
politicians and media that identify
themselves as conservative are really
functionally Scholz for large
corporations and very wealthy people and
the goal is to get the average working
person to think and behave the opposite
his own best interest to support
reaganism to support NAFTA and CAFTA and
shafte all this kind of stuff which you
know bill clinton played a big role in
it this is bipartisan but it was
considered a conservative step and it's
destroyed the manufacturing base in
America which conservatives are
delighted about the the fact that wages
have flattened out all these years
also Kirk in 1951 in the conservative
mind which is the Bible for the
conservative my father made me read that
book
as a kid and and it was fascinating it
was the book that that that started
William F Buckley going still in print
very important book to any concern any
conservator can recite chapter in
Reverse
this book and and essentially in the
book he said you know at this middle
class which is growing in 1951 if this
middle class gets too big then you're
going to see social upheaval you're
going to see people who have been
previously marginalized demanding rights
and it might even get violent and
everybody said yeah you know this is the
crazy right-wing fringe right and then
in the 60s the 60s happened in 1961 the
birth control pill was legalized came on
the market by 65 66 it was Vic witness
it was very widespread and that led to
the to you know women having now
significant control over their own
bodies saying wait a minute we would
like equality in the workplace as well
we had the civil rights movement the
1960s african-americans saying we would
like rights you have the beginning of
the gay rights movement Stonewall and
all that and and saying what about us
and and you had young people saying hell
no I'm not going to go to Vietnam you
know define their elders to find their
own government and which was exactly
what Russell Kirk had predicted and
conservatives look at this and said oh
my god this is and and riots and was in
response almost always to police
violence in the inner cities African are
parts of the seized and you know why
it's Detroit they're all inflamed and
the Conservatives said oh you know
Russell Kirk was right we've got to
reduce the size of the middle class
reduce the wealth of the middle class so
that people don't feel free to go out
and riot I mean I hit in 68 I was out in
the streets and grammar driving in East
Lansing Michigan when you know the
police were throwing tear gas grenades
at us and and the the the essence of the
whole thing was you know I I paid for my
college tuition working as a part-time
DJ making two dollars and thirty five
cents an hour at working as a dishwasher
at Bob's Big Boy and changing tires and
pumping gas at the local Exxon station
mostly in the summer you could work your
way through college by my wife worked
her way through through through college
working as a way
Howard Johnsons so we felt empowered you
know if we were out in the streets
protesting the policies of our
government we didn't feel that we would
be wiped out and that the rest of our
lives would be destroyed nowadays if you
got twenty thirty thousand dollars in
college debt you're only halfway through
your college career and you get you get
in trouble for protesting and suddenly
now you've got a police record now you
can't get credit you know bloody bloody
blood like the the lockdown of dissent
in the United States has been driven in
large part by economics since the 80s
this has been the in my opinion the
essence of Reaganism and and you could
say it has led to a more stable society
which was the concern a yeah the big big
classic difference between liberals and
conservatives is that liberals suggest
I'm going all the way back to - to John
Locke and Thomas Jefferson who said that
the US Constitution should be revised
every 19 years which is one generation
liberals would say social change if it's
in a positive direction should go
forward and should go forward as fast as
possible and if we make mistakes we'll
fix those mistakes and keep going
conservatives on the other hand as
William F Buckley famously said a
conservative as a man who stands a
threat astride the arc of history with
his hand out shouting stop and
conservatives are all in favor of
positive social change but they wanted
to go gradual incremental and not in a
disruptive fashion both of those
arguments both of those worldviews are
legitimate the what I think is the
modern tragedy is that the word
conservative has been hijacked - as I
said my father was a conservative it was
it was a Dwight Eisenhower conservative
Dwight Eisenhower ran in 1956 you out
there go to your Google machine and look
up 1956 Republican party platform right
Dwight Eisenhower ran for re-election on
a platform that said we have expanded
social security we've increased Social
Security payments we've added more than
two million new people to Social
Security we've expanded union rights
we've added you know X million new union
members we are Groot you know where
we're building the the highway system
across the country we're building out
our national infrastructure were you
know I can't think frankly and I you
know the questions come up a couple of
times burning on my program a couple of
years ago was talking about this and he
said well I I don't want a quote burning
I'll quote myself I can't think of any
positions that burning is holding right
now
that Eisenhower wouldn't have supported
that's how much it see I think America
has always been an Eisenhower kind of
country today that would be referred to
as democratic socialism or center-left
or some whatever but I think both the
Democratic and Republican parties have
moved so far and it's not even to the
right is to the corporate side to the
billionaire side to represent their
interests that the average working
person is like I'm screwed you know here
we are out in the middle of nothing
enough so and that's why I think you
know Bernie pulls 20 percent of the
Republican vote in Vermont
you know reliably and predictably
because those are the those are my dad
Republicans those are the Eisenhower
Republicans the Republicans who get it
but you know if you have a healthy
middle class you have a healthy country
we are talking on book TV with author
and radio talk show host Tom Hartman and
his most recent books include rebooting
the American Dream 11 ways to rebuild
our country the Thom Hartmann reader
came out in 2011 the crash of 2016
came out in 2013 as well the last hours
of humanity warming the world to
extinction about global warming also in
2013 the American Revolution of 1800 how
chef erson rescued democracy from
tyranny infection and what this means
today 40th anniversary edition as that
came out in 2014 and death in the pines
which happens to be a novel yeah which
actually are which I wrote about 14 15
years ago and got published this year I
got around a public well you've been
talking about Bernie Sanders we want to
show our viewers a little bit of
you interviewing or chatting with
senator Sanders on your show then we're
going to show you tom Hartman's answers
- here are a few of my favorite things
and our show will continue live in just
a few minutes
over and over again I think you can boil
the entire conservative economic agenda
down to two words cheap labor that's
right
cheap labor and defense of the largest
corporations in this country and the
wealthiest people and I think that what
we have got to do as a nation and I know
we're in the last days of a very intense
campaign and all kinds of ads are going
on the air but I think we've got to calm
down a little bit and just ask ourselves
some very basic questions and one of the
questions you know one ask its what
Ronald Reagan asked in 1980 Mario you're
better today you were better off today
than anywhere for years very simple
question and the answer to that is for
some people for all of you out there
what millionaires and billionaires if
you're not concerned about the future of
this country you're not worried about
your kids in your grandchildren for your
own economic reasons I can understand
that you're voting for George Bush that
is a rational decision I think a bad one
but a rational decision but if you are
an ordinary working people person you
have a President of the United States
who has changed federal labor standards
the federal labor standards act to throw
six million workers off of overtime
that's you friend and you're going to
vote for George Bush
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Tom Hartman who is Jack Vance and what
is shy or shy yeah I'm not sure ESPA
Jack Vance is a science fiction writer
in large part he also used to write for
Ellery Queen he wrote the detective
novels and he's written a lot of other
things but his science fiction is
spectacular
and and from the time I was able to read
I've been a science-fiction junkie and
Jack Vance just recently passed away his
writing is of such an extraordinary
caliber that I consider it literature
not just science fiction and it's just
brilliant brilliant writing and I own
every book he's ever written and I've
been collecting his stuff from the time
I was in my 20s and when my ATD book was
published in what was 96 are there about
Tim Underwood who was the owner of
Underwood books published the book was
also publishing Jack Vance and I didn't
know that and one day I was out of the
west coast and Tim Connie I was in the
San Francisco Bay Area in San Fran Tim
and Tim called me up and said hey I'm
going over to Jack dancers house for
dinner would you like join me and I mean
this is like 15 20 years ago some some
time ago I was like wow you know jack
Danson so I went to dinner and got to
know him and his wife Norma and son John
and they're just amazing and then and
then when we were living at Atlanta at
the time when Jack went to Florida he
drove the floor he was becoming blind at
that point in time when he drove to
Florida his wife drove him down to
Florida to accept the Grand Master
science fiction one of the top science
fiction Awards they stopped at our house
in Atlanta and stayed there for three
days and Jack in my office wrote one of
it actually wrote me into one of his
last books and I just I love Jack
Vance's writing I one of your people had
asked me what are you reading right now
and I said shy by Jack Vance and
you know and I'm rereading it probably
for the fourth time although it's been a
decade since the last time I read it so
it seems all new again your publisher it
for the most part is a group called
berrett-koehler networks established
most of my economic and political books
although machette published the crash
2016 write twelve imprint huh
and it was the only one that I could
find and Random House Random House
published or no yeah Random House
published last hours of entrance online
focus your energy was published by by
Pocket Books or by penguin rather I
can't keep it all straight ups to you
did you choose the I guess my question
was did you choose to go to
berrett-koehler for some reason it's a
really good publishing company
my agent established our relationship
with them and I was really pleased that
he did berrett-koehler even has a
foundation that does good works you know
out of the profits from from selling
books the base in San Francisco as I
recall and they they just really care
about books they care about authors they
take good care of their authors they get
they keep the books in print they
haven't gone full corporate like the big
publishers have we asked you what are
your favorite books that you've written
what are they that I've written right I
think that probably a couple of the most
consequential books that I've written
that have had that I have had or have
the potential have a lot of impact last
hours of ancient sunlight which I wrote
in the 90s which is about the ancient
sunlight of oil oil was captured as
sunlight 300 million years ago as plant
material settle in the ground got
compressed over time and turned into oil
and it was about the the end of the era
of oil and a book called walk in your
blues away which is a kind of a
do-it-yourself psychotherapy book in
which in there and doing the research
for that I discovered an astonishing
thing about Sigmund Freud that I don't
think anybody else has ever
known and I think that book has the
potential to actually change a lot of
psychotherapy a lot of what's going on
in that field what did you discover
about Sigmund Freud well it goes back a
little bit when I studied NLP under
Richard Bandler who is the founder of
NLP and he wrote the introduction to a
book about NLP and ATD called healing
AEDs I wrote he talked about how when we
have bad memories painful memories we or
any kind of memory actually we store
them in specific places if if I were to
ask ask you Peter what color is the
floor in your kitchen at home what color
is it
I it's wood okay so you just look down
into your right so that's where you
store that there's a there's a place in
your brain that correlates with wherever
your eyes go your eyes are actually this
is actually part of our brain that's
physically available to us the eyes are
the only part of the brain that expect
that can reach the outside of the body
and and they reflect activity going on
in the brain so a person may store this
memory over here in this memory over
here and another bedroom over here and
sometimes we store them just as feelings
which case we tend to store them in here
or sometimes here or whatever and so
what Richard had developed was a
technique where you would move the
location of the memory he concluded that
the the place where the memory is stored
is part of a giant filing system in the
brain and that the filing system
actually has a method to it and that the
method is emotion so we tend to store
things in particular places based on the
emotions in other words brain sorts by
emotion and the way it works is when we
fall asleep at night the there's a
one-day scratchpad at the base of the
brain is called hippocampus and it
basically knows everything that happened
today the hippocampus does not know time
beyond now or this day it's all of those
and at night when we sleep when we dream
the hippocampus or this is the best most
widely accepted theory about what goes
on the hippocampus is dumping the day's
activities
to the rest of the brain the rest the
cortex to process and figure out what to
keep what to throw away and where to
store it and we call this dreaming and
it seems in Colette and confusing and
primal but really it's the you know the
brain is sorting stuff by emotion not by
logic and and with post-traumatic stress
disorder what happens is somebody during
the course of a day experiences
something so horrible you know the the
death of a comrade in war a car accident
you know the people who were witnesses
to the shooting and ordered the police
officers who came and had to look at
these awful bullet riddled bodies you go
to sleep and your hippocampus is okay
here's what happened today and the rest
of the brains as well can't handle out
just hang on to it for another day and
so you wake up the next day and that
memory is just as if it happened that
day you talk to somebody with PTSD and
they'll say 20 years ago this happened
to me but I remember it like it was this
morning that's the best the one
consistent clarion characteristic of
true post-traumatic stress disorder and
so what Richard said was that memory in
the hippocampus is associated with
memories in the rest of the cortex if
you can if you can start breaking those
down into component pieces the brain can
absorb them take them out of the
hippocampus and end the PTSD and the way
that he did it was you would say okay
we'll take a memory and we'll just
change it someplace so changes location
so for example if you can think of some
minor irritation that you've had in the
last couple of weeks a waiter who
treated you badly something you know a
taxi driver who is a lousy can you think
of one yes okay
where is it when you when you when you
think of that memory I'm not going to
ask you what the memory is I'm just
asking it you know where when you look
when you look at it where is it
right over here back over here yeah okay
so grab that picture and move it over
there and now make it black and white
can you do that I don't know probably
and then run it backwards but what
happened what Richard found was that you
know you're laughing does your feeling
did you actually move to the picture no
not at all I was also thinking my right
you don't get a play talk-show host on
this part or psychologist yes but that's
the essence of it was that if you can
get people to move their memories that
the meaning of those memories change
because they've gone to a different
filing place so this has gone from the
filing place of god-awful horrible
experience into the filing place of hope
that was kind of funny and so and the
way that he would do this is he would
have people move their eyes back and
forth and back and forth and it's also
when your eyes crossed the midpoint
you're shifting from one side of the one
hemisphere of the brain to the other
hemisphere of the brain and the
hippocampus is like brain stem so it's
whole brain but you know we've got a
logical brain an emotional brain
essentially I'm hyper simplifying and
but and the goal is to fully integrate
these horrible memories so that they can
be appropriately processed so by moving
the eyes back and forth across the
center point you are smearing the memory
around the brain in a way that it can be
dealt with and typically its meaning
changes and so when I started digging
into this I discovered that Francine
Shapiro has developed EMDR emotional
desensitization reintegration and II I
don't it's been years since I wrote
about it but and it's a technique that's
used by the military where basically a
person sits in front of another person
and says watch my finger while you're
thinking about that horrible event and
things change and they change very
rapidly I was demonstrating this at
Steve Larson's place to still not in the
counseling center some years ago and
there was a fellow there who was one of
Steve's patients who had been in Vietnam
he was a guy my age he'd been in Vietnam
and was responsible for air lifting out
people who were wounded and they were on
a mountain the horrible firefight he was
pretty sure that there were no no
Vietcong around he called in the rescue
choppers they came in they landed they
loaded up he looked around said okay I
think everything's fine said take off
they got
about 300 feet up in the air and a
couple of missiles came out of the
jungle and body parts rained down on him
and as he was trying to tell us this
story he just started sobbing
uncontrollably and in fact he was on a
hundred percent disability he had been
unable to work for decades because he
would just like three or four times a
day just start burst into tears because
this memory was still today's memory so
I sat him down and I you know went
through this move this thing around
technique I wasn't using the finger when
I was just having him a little bit from
place to place out here and after about
for two or three-minute rounds of doing
this suddenly started laughing I said
why are you laughing and he said well
the memory just kind of lost his charge
and became black and white I mean that
happened like 30 years ago and I'm just
it's it's funny how I've been torturing
myself all these years for this you know
suddenly had a logical take on it and I
was like more than a decade ago maybe
fifteen years ago I got an email from
him last year saying I'm still fine
you know I'm back in the workforce and
I'm doing fine so I was wondering what
the history of this and I knew when I
was a kid I'd studied hypnosis and
hypnosis is part of NLP Milton Erickson
was probably one the most famous medical
hypnotist in the United States and
psychiatrists out of Phoenix and part of
NLP is modeled on his work so I went
back to the history of hypnosis and it
really started where guy named Franz
Anton Mesmer back in the 1760s Mesmer
was an Austrian and he discovered that
if he he used his finger he brought his
finger back and forth with his patients
and he would date he was able to solve
what hysteria was the big issue back
then you know it's which we would call
PTSD today I think in large part and it
has all kinds of physical manifestations
to people with these conditions or can
be more physically vulnerable once he
concluded that it was the moon so the
way that he did it was he would have one
hand up in the air to gather energy from
the moon and then the other hand would
be directing that energy into the person
through their eyes
and he became incredibly famous Ben
Franklin went over to France to the
Paris the French scientific society they
invited Mesmer down Mesmer thought this
to Ben Franklin they did a Ben you know
days working on this stuff Mesmer had
centers all over Europe for mesmerism it
was a big deal and but everybody you
know he was promoting as the moon which
seems kind of weird in 1834 as I recall
there was a Scottish psychologist by the
name of James Braid who said this is
nonsense this moon stuff this is
nonsense this just has to be eye fatigue
or something like that and I'm going to
prove there's got nothing to do with the
person because Mesmer was creating kind
of this cult of personality ad vyas he
had to be capable of getting the moon
energy and all this kind of stuff and he
said I'll do it with a pocketwatch
and prove you know that it's got nothing
to do with me I'm stable watch go back
and forth and it worked and brayed named
it neuro hypnosis and then the next year
he shortened that to simple hypnosis and
that's where the word came from prior to
that was called mesmerism so then you
followed the history of this through the
this is 1834 through the through the
19th century and I read I studied for
many many years ago and read studies in
hysteria the Joseph the book that he and
Joseph Brauer co-authored it was his
breakthrough book there's what made
Sigmund Freud famous it was the story of
Anna oh this one patient that they
worked on and in that book and in
numerous other papers and I cite them in
my book good walking a blues away he
said I use hypnosis I use it
diagnostically I use it therapeutically
he would use hypnosis to get to relax
people he would use hypnosis to when
they were telling their stories he would
and it was moving a finger back and
forth in front of their face or
sometimes it was stroking left arm right
arm left arm right arm but it was by
laterality was causing the brain after
shift left brain right brain left brain
right brain while experiencing or
discussing trauma and he was having
fabulous success and I mean he wrote a
book about studies in history and then
in 1898 as I recall
suddenly Sigmund Freud stopped using
hypnosis everybody stopped using
hypnosis and Freud started using cocaine
and for the next six or seven years he
was using cocaine he wrote a love
palms to cocaine he I mean that book is
still in print he was convinced the
briefing and then after a couple of
years his best friend died of a cocaine
psychosis he himself was starting to
experience cocaine psychic psychosis he
saw that it wasn't working and then he
came up with the Oedipus complex the
Electra complex in 1901 1903 and said no
it's got it all has to do with your
relationship with mother and father and
then he in the 1919 lots and teens he
developed this whole talk therapy thing
he was never able to get that mojo back
he was never able to have the kind of
successful patients that he was having
an 1898 and when he finally committed
suicide he was you know rather
embittered and depressed and unhappy and
you know as people who go through years
before you in therapy tend to get and so
I was wondering why did he stop in 1898
and I started looking through the
literature and I couldn't find it
anywhere by coincidence at that time I
was I was fascinated by a comment that
Abraham Lincoln made to Harriet Beecher
Stowe when he met her in 1861 I think it
was and she wrote Uncle Tom's Cabin and
as I recall 1843 or 48 and it was the
most widely sold widely read book in the
world Uncle Tom's Cabin at the time and
he said when he had Metairie said so
you're the little lady who started the
Civil War which to a large extent was
actually had a grain of truth anyway so
I was I was just that got me curious as
to what were the best-selling books of
the 19th century I just you know maybe
I'd like to go back and read a couple of
them and there was this book published
in 1898 by Georges des Moines a who had
also think he wrote the three the three
musketeers I might be wrong but anyhow
he had written this book and this book
was the second best-selling book in the
entire 19th century worldwide it was
called trilby most people today would
you say trilby they go huh jorge de
maria who is this guy
but everybody was reading it and the
story of trilby was the story of the
sixteen-year-old girl in france in
in Paris who was a model in an art
studio and the artists there were four
artists who had this large studio and
one of them was according to the book an
arc typical Jew this was the phrase that
demaree I used to describe this
character and he's described as a very
negative character it's a very
anti-semitic description and this man
you hypnosis the using you know the the
James Braid use a pocketwatch of your
finger hypnosis and he hypnotized this
young woman her name was trilby and
taught her how to sing and they went on
a world tour and he would hypnotize her
at night she'd go on stage she would
sing better than anybody ever sang in
the history of the world audiences loved
it he would take all the money he would
take her back to the room still in a
state of hypnosis exploit her sexually
and then in the morning she'd wake up
with no memory and tormented by you know
what's going on here and at the end of
the book she finally figures out what's
going on breaks the psychic bond with
this man and both of them died because
the bond is so like that right his name
was Bengali the bad guy so where that
word came from so and the principle
readers of this book were women
particularly upper income women in the
developed world and probably 95% of
Sigmund Freud's patients were women so
now and in the book in trilby
he describes it's a page and a half
description of a trance induction and it
was exactly the technique of Sigmund
Freud would use so these women read this
book oh my god you know somebody
hypnotizes you they could steal your
soul and make you do all these things
all all these horrible things will
happen and then one of these women walks
into the office of a Jewish psychiatrist
who says sit down and followed by figure
and he can run out screaming right so as
a result in my opinion and I have
nothing other than the history
historical timeline to back this up but
hypnotism just like vanished in 1898 and
because I believe of probing and it took
70 years for it to come back it was the
1950s the Milton Erickson started you
know really aggressively promoting
medical hip
in the United States so the technique at
that time I was teaching NLP and I had
as and I was doing a kind of a
consulting practice over the telephone
mostly with psychologists psychiatrists
psychotherapists and and doing workshops
all around the world on this and I
started with many of the therapists who
were who would call me up and say okay
you know how do I do this with that you
know how do I use NLP with this
situation I say instead of paying me my
hourly rate if you would ask some of
your patients to just try something
really simple and let me know what
happens I'd appreciate it
have them go for a walk let me back up
just a little bit the question that my
first question started this whole thing
was PTSD isn't new right ten thousand
years ago you and me are Augie and Zog
and we go out to hunt the woolly mammoth
and the woolly mammoth decides to take
out Zog right odd is going to be pretty
bummed out and pretty traumatized but
he's got to walk five miles back to the
tribe so could it be that the process of
walking left foot right foot left foot
right foot and the opposite hand
swinging this is bilateral but the
process of walking itself was a way to
heal the brain because we are self
healing mechanisms if we if we cut
ourselves at a cut of eggs it's all
healed up now
there was a scar here from my cat just
did whole week ago and bright red and
everything now it's all healed up so why
wouldn't our brain be self-healing and
what would the mechanism be and maybe
that mechanism is walking because it's
bilateral so I said you know have your
patients just go for like a 20-minute
walk every day and while they're walking
with nothing in their hands think about
the crisis that they're dealing with and
what I started getting back from these
folks was we're seeing really rapid
clinical resolutions of intractable
issues particularly PTSD and so you know
at that point I was like okay I got to
share this story so I wrote the book
walking in blues away and now you know
the whole book you don't even need to
buy it but it's basically how to you
know kind of do-it-yourself
psychotherapy we have a little over an
hour left with our guest Thom Hartmann
here on book TV 202 is the area code
for eight eighty two hundred for those
of you in the east and central time
zones seven four eight eight two zero
one if you live in the mountain in
Pacific you can send mr. Hartman a text
message as well two zero two seven one
seven nine six eight four will also show
you all the different ways via social
media you can get ahold of us here Larry
Centralia Washington thanks for holding
you are on with author Tom Hartman yes
Tom Hartman what an honor to speak with
you I'm older than Bernie Sanders so
forgive the kid a chance
yeah I used to listen to you in Portland
Oregon when you were living there and in
the selvedge district yeah but anyway I
was wondering I hear comments from the
this really believe that Becky was Sarah
Palin saying that Bernie Sanders is a
socialist and we had we're supposed to
say socialist is next to communist and
then it's a bad word well half the
country already is a socialist if you
look around and especially Sarah Palin
should get well money from the oil
companies but anyway while I think a
good society is a blend of the two
socialism and capitalism because not
everything has to be for profit and the
other thing I want to wonder is why we
never see the war machinery rolling off
assembly lines Larry what do you do
Larry what are you retired from the
barber thank you sir have you have your
political views over the years differed
have you changed yes I used to say there
was a nickel source of difference
between Republicans and Democrats and
that was I grew up under FDR and Harry
chillin and then Eisenhower and I
thought they were pretty equal parties
but I think they've all shifted so far
to the right that the the Republicans
have gone into insanity and the
Democrats are gone into the real
Republican Lord thank you sir for
calling in today yeah the
list canard is an interesting one if you
if you believe in having Social Security
you are a socialist if you believe in
having free public education you're a
socialist if you believe you know or at
least a democratic socialist which is
what Bernie calls himself if you believe
in public streets you're a socialist I
mean America was founded on on
socialists and semi socialist values as
well as free market values the kind of
democratic socialism that Bernie talks
about is let's clearly define what is
the public sphere and what is the
private sphere now the problem with the
word is that the Soviet Union called
themselves the Union of Soviet Socialist
Republics USSR and so people of my
generation think socialist means Soviet
Union they were appropriating the term
they were they were not even good
communism they were basically you know
Joe Stalin Vladimir Lenin were strongmen
you know in a essentially a dictatorship
of sorts and and so you know that's not
socialism democratic socialism
democratic socialism is what we have
here in a modest amount and what the
caller was referring to Sarah Palin in
Alaska they have the Alaska Permanent
Fund and you know every year that Sarah
Palin was governor she would authorize a
check in the neighborhood of two or
three thousand dollars a year to every
man woman and child in Alaska that came
out of the interest that the Permanent
Fund was drawing on and the Permanent
Fund got that money from saying if
you're going to drill oil out of Alaskan
land you're going to pay us for those
and not a huge price but you know enough
of a price that we've got the Permanent
Fund and so it's a guaranteed minimum
income in Alaska which is even beyond
what most socialists would propose that
Sarah Palin is an advocate of or has
been historically
I and I wouldn't call her intellectually
challenged I think she's a smart woman
and but in any case so the I think that
the the word socialist is losing its
sting in large part as a consequence of
Bernie's candidacy and and it it is
stimulating a really fascinating
conversation
about where is that dividing line
between public and private in other
words there it used to be prior to the
Reagan era it was conventional wisdom
that the private that the public sector
the government sector this is what we
all collectively own is what we all
collectively administer and it should be
done for the good of all and it should
only be done in those areas that are
natural monopolies or appropriate
government functions as defined by the
Constitution others we have a military
so it's it's the most socialist of all
institutions they provide housing
medical care the clothing everything you
know food so that's something that's in
the Constitution we're going to a
military we're going to roads it's an
article one section we're going to know
these these public schools are not in
the Constitution but this is something
that we decided to do and we got more
socialist overtime on the other hand I
don't think any American wants to be
buying their blue jeans or their shoes
or their computer from a government
owned factory you know that would be
communism communism is government
control of the means of supply and
distribution we don't want that nobody
wants that I do think though that we
have wandered now as a consequence in
large part of this kind of Reagan istic
theory that government can do no right
and that the private sector always does
right which is both of those canards are
demonstrably false we've wandered into
the area of privatizing things that
should have been privatized you've got
you know the epa having to hire a
private for-profit contractor to look
into the old gold mine you know where
they had the spill into the Animas River
a couple of months ago and what's a
for-profit company doing that kind of
stuff for a for-profit companies are
incorporated first and foremost to make
money which means that that company's
going to be looking for every corner
that they can cut uh you know I'm not
sure with really dangerous stuff like
cleaning up mine sites that we should be
having it being done that way it should
be done by somebody whose first
commitment is to cleaning up mine sites
which would be a nonprofit corporation
if you're going to outsource it or would
be government employees but the
government employees of the EPA but
steadily cut over the years or at least
though the size that it should be now is
considerably smaller than what it is and
so they've had to outsource these things
with our military were outsourcing
things and and so you end up with the
head snowden's of the world I mean he
didn't work for the government he worked
for a private corporation that was
taking money from the government to do
what should be a government function so
number one I think that we've just
speaking for myself I think that we've
gone way too far in this whole
privatization Romania and there are
things that the government actually can
do well and does do well that we should
be encouraging the government to do and
and and number two we should be looking
at this area of natural monopolies how
many power companies can bring power to
your house one how many companies can
can bring cable TV into your house
typically one on your telephone service
in your house typically one so it's
these are as septic coming out of your
house the sewage coming and the water
coming into your house these are all
natural monopolies you don't have five
power lines coming into your house you
can pick which one you're going to buy
from today based on the free market so
if these are going to be natural
monopolies then they should either be
not-for-profit corporations or they
should be government entities about half
the electricity generated the United
States is generated by community on
power centers they are consistently
higher higher reliability higher
performance lower cost than the
for-profit ones because they don't have
the skin 20% off the top to pay their
CEOs millions of dollars they don't have
to skim money off the top to give to
their to their stockholders for
dividends and because their mission
statement is not we're here to make
money their mission statement is we're
here to make sure that you've got
reliable electricity and when I lived in
Portland for example PGE which had been
spun off from Enron was selling itself
and the city of Portland wanted to buy
it and they offered the asking price MPG
he said no we will not sell it to a
government entity we will only sell it
to another private entity they were you
know so locked into this mindset of only
the the free marketing quotes but I'm a
total free market as you mentioned in
the beginning of the show I'm a serial
capitalist or a serial entrepreneur I'm
not a serial capitalist and I think that
you know it's time for us to have that
conversation you know have we gone too
far is it time for us to really start
looking at the fundamental principles of
how we organize our economy and how we
organize our way of life by the way the
distinction between capitalism and free
enterprise is an important one there I
get people calling you to show all the
time
usually conservatives who don't
understand what conservative means they
call themselves conservatives and
they'll and and they'll say well I'm a
capitalist and I'm like really how much
money did you make from your investments
last year I you know thirty five dollars
on my IRA um you know well then you're
not a capitalist capitalists are people
who live off capital literally
capitalist is a person who invest their
money and lives off their investment and
somewhere back in the last 50 years we
decided that that was such a noble thing
that we would give them a different tax
rate than people like you and me work
for a living and and so you know you or
I could run up against a thirty nine
percent tax rate capitalists right now I
have a maximum twenty percent capital
gains tax so their income it's a ceiling
at 20 percent you know whereas a brain
surgeons income hits a ceiling at 39
percent this makes no sense to me this
is crazy and in fact Ronald Reagan said
it was crazy he said you know do you
think that a millionaire should be
paying a lower income tax rate than a
bus driver and the he was speaking in a
high school and the kids all you know
and he said you're right they shouldn't
and for one year during the Reagan
administration the capital gains tax in
it and the ordinary income tax were
identical twenty-eight percent for one
year and then the corporation's got the
better oregan and this is the split
broke back out again that was 83 or 84
so you know there's really not that many
capitalists in the United States is
probably fewer than a couple hundred
thousand people who are literally living
other than retired people who are
literally living off their investments
who put money into companies and then
just live off that from your book
screwed mr. heartland Larry from
Centralia said he didn't see a dimes
worth of difference between the parties
you asked the question what about
creating a third party yeah I I think
I've I don't remember what I wrote about
their party it's been more than more
than a decade since I wrote that book
but or in the neighborhood of a decade
but one thing that I do believe right
now and this is why I think Bernie's
candidacy is so noble is that I mean you
look
it's not true that Ralph Nader cost Al
Gore the election in 2000 but it is
widely believed and but typically what
happens is third parties end up harming
the party the the mainstream party
that's closest to them because they
siphon votes away from them so Bernie
says you know I'm going to run in the
Democratic primary and if I don't get it
I'm not going to run and you know God
bless him that's the way to do or they
say alternative parties have an
important place in American politics he
right and those in them should continue
to work for their strength and vitality
they're essential as incubators of ideas
and Nexus points for activism that does
not mean however that they are an
alternative to the two mainstream
parties when election time rolls around
yeah so I'm consistent in my in my
philosophy I think the Green Party in
the Libertarian Party are great in that
they stir conversations on the edges
that move then into the major parties on
the other hand I don't think it's great
when a politician of say you could do it
Republican or Democrat but but a
district that really typically would
vote Democratic ends up with a
Republican member of Congress because
the Green Party was real active in that
district or to a party that which
district that were typically elected
Republican to Congress ends up with a
Democrat because the Libertarian Party
was super active in that district you
know at the level of the vote it becomes
problematic the at the level of ideas
good stuff Scott in San Diego please go
ahead with your question of comment for
Thom Hartmann good morning Peter good
morning Tom in the morning c-span Tom
you're the brightest guy on talk radio
today you've got heart and you've got
smarts which are two things that are in
very short supply in what passes for
political discourse today so here's my
question your association with Bernie
Sanders as a radio guest goes back
decades when he was beginning in local
politics back in Vermont so it's safe to
say that you've gotten to know him
pretty well as a politician and as a
human being so what is something about
senator Sanders that most voters don't
know that if they did know it they were
on
and why he'd make an awesome president
and also as of right now how would you
gauge his chances of being nominated an
election okay with regard to his chances
I I just don't know it's you know these
things are very very difficult to to
predict with regard to who is Bernie
I'll just tell you a quick story when we
were first talking about Bernie being on
our show he had been on the program a
couple of times and we were thinking
about making it a regular feature of the
show which is a real break in the format
of my show the format because basically
you know Bernie becomes the show for an
hour and and usually it's callers
calling me and such to call it caller
calling Bernie and I'm just plain MC so
we were going to get together in
Burlington and and talk about this and
just have a conversation so Louise and I
show up at the restaurant and Bernie's
guy it was Huck shows up and and Bernie
comes in you know like a whirlwind you
know is his hair askew and you know and
on the phone right and we're sitting
there and he kind of comes over and kind
of half sits down and he says really
really oh okay I'll be I'll be there
I'll be there in 30 minutes
don't worry I don't know I will be there
any hang of the phone and he grew and
this waitress is walking by and it
doesn't physically grab it but he grabs
the waitress and he says bring me
something with chicken and she's like
look and he says right now right now I
got a run and so she runs off to the
kitchen and we just sat down and he says
IBM just announced they're laying off
300 people we're assembling a group but
this is 7 o'clock at night we're
assembling a group of people in front of
their Factory and a half hour for a
demonstration I've got to be there he
was the congressman from Vermont that's
that was the one and only time I've ever
had a meal with Bernie I mean you know
is Bernie is all business you know I
don't know Bernie as a human being
individually beyond the many
conversations that we've had that I've
never been to his home I don't know his
family it's a bernie is so committed to
his work and to his nation but that'll
we that it always seems to come first
at least from what I can see
catherine ormond beach florida good
afternoon to you yes a wonderful show
like most Americans I support
common-sense gun regulations but I
believe our forefathers you know what
I'm going to hang up on Catherine only
because Catherine calls in all the time
as different names and always talks
about the same issue
she doesn't really add to the
conversation that we like to have with
our with our guests but um so I
apologize for that
Tom's in Chicopee Massachusetts hi Tom
yeah how are you
she's been it's great I love c-span me
too and I like all the different
perspectives whatever and Tom I really
enjoy listening to it anyway I guess my
thought here is I think over the years
I've become more conservative and that
mean well for me meaning for example I
find liberals to be much more bigoted
you know when you talk about
multicultural etc so conservatives
anybody on the run conservative to you
means that you've become more tolerant
of and want to be more inclusive with
regard to people of color well I've
always I've always felt that way with
that for example myself for me I lived
in advocate for a couple years I was a
volunteer at a time when a Peace Corps
was kicked out of Tanzania I was a
volunteer there and you know I mean and
you know I've been around done some
traveling whatever and I really do enjoy
people and I like to see people do well
but I think maybe the biggest thing is
there's so much to talk about but that I
found I just gotten a little more
conservative about my opinions for
example I didn't like what's your name
Hirsi Ali not being allowed to speak at
Brandeis University I thought that was
terrible I just an experience that needs
to be heard I
I don't know who that is or what you're
talking about so I cancelled Tom in
Chicopee Massachusetts do you listen to
Tom Hartman's radio show uh no I haven't
gob did you have a special rush and
that's why I'm glad you're listening to
speak to Shafter Noonan all right well
we appreciate your listening and I want
to follow that up with a this email from
Pam in Birmingham Alabama and this might
be part of it an earlier caller
mentioned NAFTA pass during a democratic
administration so it seems it makes no
difference which party is in power that
makes people get cynical about the
system Here I am a Democrat in a red
state what can we do to change minds and
hearts this is a real problem for the
Democratic Party
alfe from talks about this in his book
from a couple years ago how back in the
late 80s in fact rather than quoting
help from let me just put this in my own
words Reagan had declared war on
organized labor in 81 busting a patco
and you know all these things appointing
the first anti labor secretary of labor
in the history of the United States and
etc and the as as labor was collapsing
in their asset base there you know as
unions were getting smaller they were
also getting less wealthy and unions had
traditionally been a large source of
money for the Democratic Party and so
the Democrats so some strategic
Democrats like L Fromm we're looking
around going okay the Indian money is
going away what's next
how do we survive as a political party
the Republicans have survived as a
political party basically by being on
the side of big business and you know
it's a party of business and back when
what was good for General Motors is good
for America you could argue that was
even a good thing but the Democrats had
been the party of labor so now we can't
be labor anymore or do you do well
there's some businesses out there that
are less toxic than others so instead of
being the party of the tobacco industry
which the Republicans were firmly in
talkative back in the eighties let's
become the party of the banks they're
not toxic you know and they got a lot of
money let's become the party of big
business but softer business its
businesses that everybody respects and
so the Democratic Party through the
Democratic Leadership Council in the
third way and all this kind of stuff and
Alfama in this book talks about going
down to Arkansas when Bill Clinton was
governor and sit them down and saying
you want to join me in this thing we're
going to we're going to take over the
Democratic Party we're going to rebrand
it essentially and I'll make you present
and and that's what happened the
Democratic Party has become by and large
since 1991 or 92 has become the party of
some big businesses and this is where
Bernie Sanders is making a turn away
from this saying no we're not going to
be the party of any business we're going
to be the party of the people of the
people of the United States let the
republicans be the party the
billionaires and be the party of the of
the big corporations that's why I asked
Tom you know what being a conservative
meant to him because when you ask people
is sometimes you'll say well I'm opposed
to abortion well you know I don't know
if that's a conservative or liberal
position or you know I've got four guns
and I don't I don't want to give them up
well I'm not sure that that's how do
these become partisan issues this should
be issues that we discuss you know
opposed to abortion I'm of evangelical
Christian what does that have to do with
politics so what has happened is that
the party which is representing a very
small slice and doing a very good job of
representing that very small slice of
the 1% in America has can't get elected
the Republican Party can't get elected
if they were simply to say we are the
party of the billionaires really the
party the transnational corporations it
was a NAFTA for example was passed yes
it was signed by Bill Clinton but it was
mostly Republicans who voted for the
Democrats were very opposed to it and
and we're going to be the part you know
if they simply said we're the party big
business nobody would vote for them so
instead they go okay you got you got 15
million evangelical Christians we'll
pick them up you got 20 million
homophobes will pick them up you got a
hundred million racists
we'll pick them up you got you got the
30 million people who hate abortion
we'll pick them up there is they take
these issues that don't hurt big
business at all the billionaire's don't
give a rat's patootie about and say you
know we'll take strong positions with
these groups and we'll pick it and so
it's become essentially a coalition it's
sort of like the way that that you know
parliamentary governments are governed
you know with coalition and and and I
think that that and and and thus people
say okay well I guess if I'm opposed to
abortion or if if I'm an evangelical
Christian or whatever I must be there
for a Republican because the Republican
Party has told me that over number again
and you know I think it's an unfortunate
bifurcation in our politics an
unnecessary one and the Democratic Party
has you know once they once they started
selling out to big corporations in the
90s they didn't stop and although the
Progressive Caucus in the Democratic
Party is the largest or second largest
caucus in the US Congress they still are
consistently marginalized by the
corporate Democrats and my sense of it
and I write about this in the crash in
2016 although not so much at the level
of party is that a good sized economic
crisis might shake up the Democratic
Party enough that they go back to their
FDR harry truman frankly Lyndon Johnson
roots Jack Kennedy this is a quote that
you called the most profound comment
I've ever heard about foreign policy and
human nature I don't know why America
always thinks she has to run around the
world forcing people to take our way of
governments at the barrel of a gun when
you got something really good and you
don't have to force it on people they
will steal it
yeah yeah I was Dick Gregory and I were
flying to Uganda during the war with Idi
Amin and the International charity
organization that I mentioned set up a
program there which is still there it's
still running
Salem International is the website to
see org and we started talking politics
and he made that comment to me he says
and only he said it with the perfect
comedians timing you know you got
something good you don't have to force
it on people or the barrel of a gun they
will steal it
that's like and that's what's happening
you know countries that are flipping
small d-- democratic-- they are stealing
back their countries that people are
rising up and saying we want our country
back yeah it's it's a brilliant
statement and it's one of the chapters
in rebuilding the American dream is
titled they will steal it and it's based
on that comment that's to call for us to
recalibrate our foreign policy Linda's
in Phoenix hi Linda hi I'll be as quick
as I can
they're talking about the both
Democratic and Republican parties and
also a little earlier you said that the
extremes were moving more towards the
corporations and that brought to mind to
me a quote from Mussolini fascism should
be more appropriate should more
appropriately be called corporatism
because it is a merger of state and
corporate power and I by the way I feel
the Bern
I'm a big supporter and I I know I'm a
political junkie and this just doesn't
leave my mind is through questionnaires
me greatly and I and I wanted to know if
you would comment on that and also what
you think is the TPP yeah yeah I'd be
glad to the TPP I've I call it the
southern hemisphere or the SOT southern
hemisphere Asian free trade agreement
sha FTA we've got NAFTA CAFTA and shafte
and I prefer to call the TPP shafte
because it really is the southern
hemisphere Asian free trade agreement
and you know I'm opposed to all of them
so the the oath of fascism part yeah
this is a word that was invented
actually by Giovanni Gentile who was
Mussolini's speechwriter and ghost
writer but and and who probably was the
origin of that quote but it's certainly
Mussolini said that repeatedly and in
fact when Mussolini took over the
took over Italy they dissolve the
Parliament and instead of having that
what would be our equivalent of
congressional districts elect their
representatives to the Parliament the
largest corporation in each districts
sent their representative to Parliament
so literally the and in fact he renamed
it he called it the khmer OD faso
co-opted the illness forgive my lousy
italian there's the chamber of the
fascist corporation and this merger of
corporate and state interests Henry
Wallace wrote about this in 1940 the
recall 44 the New York Times asked him
what about American fascists and he
wrote a really impeachment in New York
Times in which he said that the fascist
you have to worry about are not the
neo-nazis the fascists you have to worry
about are the corporate powers that are
reaching out for control of our
government because they already control
the economy and if they can then control
the agency which makes the rules for the
economy they will have unlimited power
and that is a danger and that is fascist
this was the vice president of the
United States in the early 1940s and the
air times and I think that you know he
was prescient it's gotten worse over
time I just don't like using the word
fascism because people think you're
talking about Nazism and the Nazis were
death called
they were not even functionally fascist
so what would be the effect in your view
of TPP if it's essentially a fascist
argument I mean you get these tribunals
these three-judge tribunals that are
made up of corporate lawyers who who
have the power to override laws made
here in the United States we've we
already saw this with NAFTA for example
the back thirty years ago the humane
society the United States started a
campaign took 24 years to do it to end
the or to change the way that tuna were
fish tuna typically swim underneath
schools of tuna swim underneath schools
of dolphins the Dolphins are
air-breathers they swept this one I'm on
the surface they're messy eaters they
eat something the stuff
filters down and the tuna eat it so
they're eating the leftovers of the
Dolphins above them and so they would
come in with these giant Nets
wherever they saw dolphins I knew they
were tunable oh they addicted his giant
Nets they pull them all up and the
Dolphins would all die and you know so
the humane society said let's require
longline fishing you know with the
fishing pole kind of fishing you have a
thousand lines but below the dolphins
down where the tuna we made this law in
the United States dolphin safe tuna its
major accomplishment and it was made a
law as a result of the public the vast
majority the public saying this is what
we want we're concerned about the future
of the dolphin sea other populations are
diminishing their mammals they're smart
they're like us in some ways you know
let's let's have humane fishing as soon
as we sign nafta farmer of fishermen in
Mexico which we're still using the per
se net sued us and said you can't have
that law that's an unfair restraint of
trade it means that our product our tuna
caught off the shores of Mexico could
not be sold in the United States that's
a violation in the North American trade
free trade agreement raid Organization
rules and we had to back down way to
change our laws I mean this and this is
there's hundreds of examples of this
that's probably one of the more famous
ones TPP will do the same thing only
only with pharmaceuticals with banking
basically the lowest common denominator
most corporate friendly least good for
the consumer policies are going to
become law that is enforced by the
corporation's themselves in courts that
are run and owned by the corporation's
themselves that have the power to
overturn United States lawmaking and my
in my opinion any conservative should be
saying hey wait a minute this is so
wrong I mean the conservative argument
against the United Nations was that it a
surrender of sovereignty we live and it
was we literally gave up our right to be
able to start a war just because we
decided we wanted to do it and said we
will not enter a war without the the
body of nations saying yes you can do
that and you know we've we've stood
there all these years
conservatives said wait a minute you're
surrendering sovereignty to the rest of
the world that's wrong we are the United
States we answer only to ourselves and
yet now many of the same people are
saying oh yeah but TPP NAFTA shafted
CAFTA all of them they're just fine it's
wonderful stuff and that's my point
about how conservative no longer means
conservative it no longer means
defending the Constitution it means now
defending the interests of big
transnational corporations and
billionaires and then they put this
patina on it to make it seem like the
average guy could vote fourth and it's
the only way that they can win elections
unfortunately this text please tell us
the name of Tom's book about EMDR I
caught his discussion and want to buy it
it's called walking your blues away
there you go
Nancy Redondo Beach California thank you
Peter and thank you Tom I just I just
love you and enjoy you so much my
question is what can the average person
like me do to really change things about
what's going on in the middle class you
know nothing theoretical just a
step-by-step you know I email I protest
and I still feel like I'm in the same
place so I'm just wondering what an
average person can do to change things
and I'll take the answer off the air
thank you very much I think that it was
Thorstein Veblen the Norwegian economist
ISM recalling it's been a lot of years
who suggested and I think McDowell and
the tipping point reprised some of this
who suggested that when a certain
percentage and it seems to be in the
neighborhood of 20 25 percent of the
population firmly believes something
that's outside the mainstream of of how
the how the society is going that the
society will change to accommodate that
new belief and I think we certainly saw
this with the Reagan Revolution it was
not a majority of Americans who agreed
that we should cut taxes on on
billionaires and cut taxes on
corporations and raise taxes 18 times on
average working people as Reagan did
it was it was a small group of people
but they were able to convince enough
people at that 2025 % to basically flip
our government so I think the thing that
you can do to most effectively change
things is wake people up have
conversations with your friends whether
it's on the telephone whether it's over
coffee in your kitchen whether it's at
the local community center whether it's
on Facebook or Twitter or your favorite
website educate your friends and your
neighbors let people know if everybody
on either side frankly I mean I would
say the same thing to Republicans of
goodwill you know we all should become
evangelists as perhaps too strong the
word but awaken errs educators and when
you when you actually have the facts on
your side it's fun and easy hi Tom my
name is Kelly text message I was
wondering if you would talk a little
about your vegetarianism love your show
on Sirius yeah I became a vegetarian
when I was 16 so it would have been 67
in response to the Vietnam War
originally it was a statement of
non-violence and within a year of that I
had gotten into TM and and other
spiritual practices that that led me to
conclude the vegetarianism was also a
more ethical way of living and then I
started reading the literature on
vegetarianism and decided that it was
probably a healthier way of eating and
so you know I've been a vegetarian ever
since then and mostly these days of
vegan I think that you can make an
argument that eating small fatty fish
periodically like once a week there was
a study that was just done a couple of
months ago that you can find actually
I'm not sure that the website that any
other that found it was a study of
Nordic populations and they found that
the people who ate small fatty fish one
serving once a week or more had better
cognitive abilities as they aged past 50
than the people who ate none at all
so on
if if somebody was eating for maximum
health that would be the one caveat I
would put on it which I'm sure has got
every vegetarian and vegan in the
country going yeah but you know kippered
herring sardines that kind of thing
these small fatty fish that that are not
high on the food chain they don't
they're not filled with mercury and
poisons but that that's the the only
caveat I've I feel great and we raised
our kids vegetarian we've you know I've
seen it works and it's it's walking
lightly on the earth - you know it's
your I think their center set up for
food density the the more a food is you
know like you take a hundred pounds of
grain and you run it through a cow and
you end up with a pound of beef I think
that that's denser food and we've as
we've shifted to denser and denser food
over the last couple of decades
mostly with fast foods but you know
we're starting to have weight problems I
suspect that there's something there -
when I when I eat vegan I feel lighter
it just it feels better to me who is mr.
Stanley Master Stan I said other
spiritual practices Master Stanley was a
fellow who was a he ran he was the
pastor of the Coptic temple in Detroit
for fifty-six Ledyard Street in downtown
Detroit used to be the governor's
mansion back in the 1920s and a big old
building and I became his student when I
was 17 I went through a couple years of
kind of learning the stuff that there's
a Christian organization that had some
very loose ties to the Orthodox Coptic
Church Egypt but very very loose it was
Hamid Bey actually started it and he
came to United States in the 1920s him
and Paramahansa Yogananda did tours
around the country could stop his heart
and stuff and he was on you asked for
the famous TV show we died brought back
to life and Master Stanley prescribed
vegetarianism it was a big fan of it for
spiritual practice and you know so I got
into that and then when master Stanley
died for
a couple of years I John Davis 9 a
couple of other people became I was one
of the rotating pastors for that church
so I was ordained I've done a bunch of
weddings and things over the years but
yeah so are you a Coptic Christian today
uh - yeah if I had to choose an
affiliation sure and what is the
difference between mainstream
Christianity and Coptic Christian well
the master stanley's Coptic organization
has its based in Grand Rapids John
Davis's Ronnie who was along with me in
a bunch and group of about 12 other
people were kind of hardcore disciples
of Master Stanley's has become a more
like unity like the you know or the more
progressive denominations that are
willing to entertain things like
meditation and vegetarianism so it's not
the the let's dress up and look all
pompous like the official Orthodox
Coptic Church Hamid Bey was an Orthodox
priest who went rogue eric is calling in
from Erie PA hi Eric good morning Yvonne
afternoon gentlemen time it's lawsuit
eric canary i want i'd love to have in
this forum here with where we get to
discuss your books at length and get off
the daily politics i wanted to know what
maybe your takeaway is on now that we've
got a lot of years of data on these ATD
adhdboys that were heavily medicated in
a kind of a knee-jerk reaction i was one
of them in the 70s and what we've seen
in the manifestations in their later
life particularly relating to ways they
seek to balance their own brain
chemistry later self medication or
depression things like that what's your
take away in terms of of that and and
also i carry the message man whenever I
encounter a kid that's getting the a DD
rap I take them aside and I say listen
this is an advantage there's something
you can do there you can do a lot of
things that nobody can do sure maybe you
can't do a couple things that everyone
can do but
but you've got powers that they don't
have so fine O's use those yeah uh
excellent questions consequences of meds
and school okay here's here's first of
all my hypothesis on a DD i-- when my
son went through this i it provoked this
you know sort of like with the hypnosis
stuff how did this happen where did this
come from what's going on with this and
it occurred to me that prior to the
Agricultural Revolution which was only
ten or eleven thousand years ago we were
all hunter-gatherers and in a hunting
gathering sucide a DD is characterized
by three principal behaviors
distractibility impulsivity and a need
for high levels of stimulation high
levels of arousal so in school we view
those things you know the
distractibility the kids looking at the
bug on the ceiling settle listening the
teacher impulsivity the kid is
interrupting people and blurting things
out need prior level of stimulation the
kid is constantly getting into trouble
or you know he's figuring out ways to be
stimulated basically and it's behavior
that we try to crush in schools
historically but if we were you know
hunting-gathering society and we're
going through the forest looking for
lunch and we're not constantly scanning
the environment we might miss that
rabbit that just ran by that's going to
be lunch or we might miss that bear back
there that wants to make us lunch
so distractibility would be an asset in
that world impulsivity you're chasing a
deer through the forest or you're
chasing a rabbit to the forest and a
deer fly runs by what do I do go after
the deer go after the rabbit let's sit
down and make a graph here and on one
side we'll put deer the other side we'll
put rabbit with assets and liabilities
let's say the deer is more meat but he's
going to be harder to catch it no you
don't have time for that right you have
to make an instant decision and act on
and literally the textbook and
dictionary definition of impulsivity is
behavior preceding cognition in other
words we act before we think about it
that would be an asset in that world not
a liability and the need for high levels
of stimulation and arousal well who's
going to get up in the morning and say I
think I'll go out there in the jungle or
in the in the forest where there are
things that
me as much as I want to eat them and
find lunch right what kind of person
would do that somebody who is not
intimidated by high levels of arousal in
fact somebody the best hunters would be
the people who love that now oh boy
adventure so that's a dee dee those are
hunters hundred gathers but then you
know when the farming revolution came
along those skills are the opposite of
what you need in farmers once you settle
out as a farmer you go out you plant
your wheat you set in your front porch
for three weeks waiting for the little
shoots to come up and you just sit there
right waiting for the weak to grow and
for somebody who's a TD that would be
painful but for somebody who's a good
farmer hey I can just sit here and I
don't need a lot of arousal and I'm not
going to make any impulsive decisions
and I'm you know and and then when the
harvest comes in going out and picking
bugs off plants day after day hour after
hour week after week month after month
just picking bugs off plants if this is
what we did and that then became putting
a bolt on a nut in a nut on a bolt or
whatever the proper language is in a car
factory or on an assembly line you know
we all became farmers basically and we
built our schools literally out of this
agricultural model so much so that we
take summer off so the kids can bring
the crops in and and elloe on the
industrial model that Henry Ford
pioneered with the assembly line our
schools have become assembly lines so
our schools are structurally hostile so
the kind of brain wiring that brought
the human race to where it's at you know
the Ben Franklin's and Thomas Edison's
and both of whom dropped out of high
school affected and Thomas Thomas Edison
was kicked out when he was seven years
old and so the you know that's why you
know I say if you have a TD or a hunter
in a farmer's world so then the question
of medication what do you do about this
paradoxically stimulant medications
produce a sense of stimulation which
causes people who need a sense of
stimulation to relax because now hey I'm
stimulated so I can sit here and pay
attention so the question then is if
you're going to have a farmer based
class
do you medicate your kids or not turn
them into farmers because basically what
stimulant medications does they turn 100
kids into farmer kids and this has to do
I believe the mechanism has to do with
dopamine and planet gain and there's
this whole scientific explanation that I
can lay on you but it's probably far
more granular than we need to get I
personally believe and and I've seen
this and a lot of kids and although we
weren't using meds in the in the program
for abuse kids that we started back in
the 70s back in 78 but I've seen in my
own family and I've seen others not
about my kids but my brothers and and
friends and whatnot I personally think
that failure in school is more
destructive to a child than taking a
stimulant medication now time may prove
me wrong but I'm not an absolute
opponent of stimula medications for kids
and I've tried them myself I know how
they work and I I know that I can focus
better when I take them I'm just I just
don't like the way I feel I would much
rather you know but but I think this is
this is you know like a lot of people
who got caught up in cocaine and meth
they're probably ATD people because
these are stimulants and they bring them
down you know or they stabilize so that
they can function in boring jobs we once
had a book a bookkeeper who screwed up
our taxes year after year he was the
cousin of a close friend of mine and
finally as I sat him down and said you
know he was so ATD but his father dinner
bookkeepers grandfather bookkeeper
that's a new so ad shouldn't be a
bookkeeper he said what should I do I
said you should be a Salesman for your
accounting company get out there you
know selling is a hunting job you're on
the hunt and he shifted instead he
became a salesman for accounting
services and started and really grew the
firm and stopped screwing up my taxes
you know is a wonderful thing so but
that said I would say that providing
medication is a step but it's I don't
think it's the optimal step I think the
optimal step is to reinvent our schools
so that they're hunter friendly as well
as farmer friendly then we won't need
the medications that if I you know
that's one of the Crusades that I've
launched with my books I've written a
couple of books about reinvent
schools probably most comprehensive one
is Tom Hartman complete guide to ADHD
where I go back into the history of the
schools and queen Theresa of Austria we
started the first inin Chulan in the
late 1700s early 1800s and in Austria
where parents would bring their children
and half the year they would spin cloth
and the other half they would be
educated and and the education was how
the government paid for the or the
spinning of the Claus is how they paid
for the education and the education was
what the kids got in exchange for the
work that they did and then over time
that change to a public school model as
we outlawed child labor and anyhow I go
through all that the whole history of
Education Diana your own book TV with
Tom Hartman Diana's and Galesburg
Illinois hey Diane hi
I love the c-span just wanted you to
know my question tom is you do support
Bernie quite readily and I do think he's
a good person
and I have always followed his you know
programming on your program however I
don't think that I could vote for him
and the reason is that he is for the
drone program and he's very strongly
militarily involved with the drone
program and I do I just I couldn't vote
for him so thank you for your time and
let me know how you respond to that
Thanks
sure I IRA burning he's been a guest on
my program every Friday for a lot of
years and I've never heard him speak
highly of drones I I would have to you
know feel the Bern org is probably the
best website for Bernie's positions on
the issues I'd have to go there and look
it up but all that said I you know yes I
support Bernie Sanders I also support
Hillary Clinton I think that she has the
potential to be a great president and
people say oh but you know she was on
the board of directors of Walmart and
you know they take money from
corporations and they've got a super PAC
as if to imply that somehow she's
corrupt I think we need to remember the
Franklin Roosevelt was the governor of
New York state during the period which
led to the Great Depression and that all
happened in New York State that was Wall
Street his Attorney General Eric
Schneiderman the New York Attorney
General now he's going after the
banksters but Roosevelt's Attorney
General did not go after the banksters
Roosevelt was part of the Tammany Hall
machine he was being he was being
investigated for corruption for
corruptly appointing a judge when he was
running for president you could argue he
was the corrupt governor of one of the
most corrupt states in the United States
he became president of United States
during a time of great national crisis
and he flipped he became in my opinion
one of the best presidents we've ever
had and that's not to say that Hillary
Clinton is corrupt or whatever you know
but the point is that he knew what
Franklin Roosevelt knew from having been
governor of New York and and having been
as corrupt as he was he knew where the
power was he knew where the bodies were
buried he knew how to make things happen
he knew how to get things done I think
all of those are true of Hillary Clinton
I think she has tremendous leadership
potential and capabilities I would
prefer Bernie Sanders as president I
endorsed Bernie as president but if it's
Hillary I will vote for her with no
hesitation whatsoever because I think
she would be a great president
particularly in a time of crisis and I
think that we are I know that we are in
a time of crisis worldwide and I believe
that an economic crisis is coming as
well Clark Bloomfield New Jersey please
go ahead think you're going to do the
last call today okay hello gentlemen I
would I would really wanted to criticize
Tom but all right I have four things I
want to say like to it the first two
were criticisms but I'm going to let
that slide I just want to ask s you two
questions you life you said before your
life changed on the Vietnam War that
that event change your life from from
being a Republican to a Democrat
that I don't understand that because the
Vietnam War was a Democrat war it was a
it wasn't even a war with a legal action
yeah it was it was it just blows my mind
for people so you'd like him to explain
that a little bit more clutch thank you
very much yeah it first of all the
Vietnam War didn't turn me into a
Democrat I I was largely a political in
a partisan way until probably fifteen
years ago or so I was more school of a
pox on all their houses it caused me to
question my own government it caused me
to question the wisdom of politicians it
caused me to I mean a lot of us I think
who grew up in that time realized that
we had been lied to the Gulf of Tonkin
Resolution was a lie Lyndon Johnson I
think was a great president except that
he had this Vietnam War thing and yeah I
was you know it wasn't just a democratic
war a Democratic Party war I'm Richard
Nixon continued it and in fact sabotage
in 1968 nixon sabotage lyndon johnson's
attempts to negotiated truths he had
he'd actually worked it out and there's
just three years ago the Johnson library
just released the tape of Lyndon Johnson
talking to Everett Dirksen in which he's
saying you know Everett I'm reading
their hand I know they're over there
telling to not to not to negotiate with
me until after the election this is
treason and Everett Dirksen says I know
he's like can you talk to Nixon and get
him to stop at Nixon wouldn't stop but
you know any I it was a political
awakening for me it was not necessarily
a shift from Democrat Republican to
Democrat what are you going to talk
about tomorrow in the show I don't know
that's sorry
it's what's so wonderful about doing a
talk show and I'm guessing probably you
you have this sense of the two with you
know doing these shows is that you just
never know what's going to come up and
you work with what's right in front of
you and so after we're done today I'll
be going back home and going through all
the news looking for in particular the
stories that are not necessarily the
ones that everybody's talking about the
ones that actually
important things are pivoting on are you
working on another book right now mr.
Harbour yeah I'm working on a couple of
them I'm working on one about the
Supreme Court and this is an area where
I agree with Phil